Did your room experience podcast
is brought to you by tank.
If you go to [inaudible] dot [inaudible]
dot com you will save 25 bucks off of
any of their high end
cell phones or service.
Um,
if you have not,
uh,
if you're not aware of what Ting is
we've talked about on this podcast,
many times the only people that will
ever do commercials for are people whose
companies make sense to us.
People whose companies like if they have
like a good ethic to them or if they're
selling something that's really cool.
That's the only people that were
interested in getting involved in.
And we got involved with Ting because
they're what I would call a non evil
company.
Their approach is you don't
need to have contracts,
just give people a decent service at
a reasonable rate and you're gonna,
you're gonna make money.
You don't,
you don't have to make
more money and be a cunt.
And that's sort of the idea behind it.
You can quit anytime you want.
It's on the sprint backbone.
So it's a legitimate high end,
uh,
broadband service and the legitimate
high end cellular connection.
So it's not like it's,
you know,
Bob cell phone companies
making his own wires.
They use sprint.
So what you're getting is all of the,
the,
the power of a big network,
but with all,
and not all the bullshit.
You can have a couple people on the
same account and share minutes if your
minutes,
if you don't use your minutes,
you get credited and your next account,
no one is trying to fuck
you over at this company.
And that's what we like
about them and that's why,
uh,
we represent them.
So go to rogan.ting.com
and save yourself 25 bucks.
We'll also brought to
you by brought to you.
Well,
we're also brought to you by
blade slinger from kerosene games.
Uh,
if you've never played
any games on the IPAD,
one of the things that can be really
annoying is if a game is not designed for
the IPAD,
if it's like poured it
over for a computer,
then it's like the
controls are all fucked.
You know,
they're clunky.
Yeah.
This is designed specifically
for IPADS and iPhones.
And one of the cool things about
living in today's era is that you,
you get amazing visual processing
power from these little tablets,
like something that would be a
giant computer just a few years ago,
just 10 years ago is now a little thin
glass and metal piece of awesomeness.
And you can play this game on it and it's,
you know,
really high resolution graphics.
It's a super cool game and it's only two
99 and you can get it on iTunes and it
will be available very soon
for high end android devices.
They're shooting for February,
I believe.
But it's a very cool game.
If you go and look at the reviews online,
it's amazingly positive,
which is incredible because the
universe is filled with clients.
So if you can get that
many positive reviews,
you know that someone's doing
something right because,
uh,
it's,
it's a fun game to play.
It's very addictive.
So it's called Blade slinger.
It's on kerosene games
and it's three bucks.
You fucks.
All right.
Get it together.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com I was going to bring in,
uh,
a gift pack for our buddy.
I'm here,
Alex Honnold but uh,
but I forgot it unfortunately.
But on it,
if you're interested,
we'll send you a bunch of shit.
It's a supplement company that,
uh,
I'm a part of a,
I own a piece of it.
And the reason why I got involved with
it was exactly what I said earlier about
commercials.
The idea of selling something
to someone where you know,
it's not a rip off the idea
of like a reasonable exchange.
Instead of having the ethics of business
that a lot of people have where you're
just trying to squeeze
every last ounce of profit,
our idea is to sell the best shit
we can find as cheaply as we can.
We will sell you all of the cool food
items that I've gotten into that we've
talked about on the podcast,
including bulletproof coffee,
which I'm treating right now.
Um,
that's why sometimes like that's one
of the side effects of bulletproof
coffee.
The fact that the butternut goobers
yeah,
I got goobers I get a
little bit cotton mouth too,
if you know what I'm saying.
This bulletproof coffee,
if you're not aware,
and this is a fascinating thing
that I've just become aware of,
there's a real issue with foods
with something called mycotoxins.
Mycotoxins are,
is when you get coffee and uh,
you know,
and you don't know how it was taken
care of or it's even in corn number and
reading.
What happens is if it's stored incorrectly
or harvested under certain conditions
that can develop fungus and that fungus
can actually be toxic for your body.
So if you're drinking coffee like,
oh I feel like shit me,
you might have just poisoned herself.
And right now at this list just Starbucks,
Dave Asprey is actually doing research,
John,
all this stuff to try to find
out exactly what the effects are,
how prevalent they are.
But they have absolutely been measured.
This is a fact.
There's a show called dangerous
grounds where a guy is a coffee expert.
He goes to all these different really
exotic parts of the world where they
cultivate coffee.
Cause a lot of the coffee that you buy,
like my favorite stuff comes from Hawaii,
but a lot of coffee comes from like
really fucking freaky places I guess.
Yes,
it
grows better.
This you get to the bottom of this because
I live right next door to a Starbucks
like every single day I go there,
everybody knows you at.
When do we would have to do as
far as test test their coffee.
You could test my fucking
ball sweat and it's,
I mean it's probably off your ball.
That would be the,
you are the most unscientific person ever
because who knows what kind of toxins
are going into your body.
It's not like your buddies up purity
filter springwater comes out of it isn't
that way by getting rid of the toxins
you to find out if you're getting it from
Starbucks because we wouldn't,
we'd have to only feed you Starbucks
for that scientific project to work.
Well,
I don't eat or do anything except a Trenta
Starbucks for the first six hours I'm
awake.
We'll do you shit.
You've eaten the last couple
of weeks could turn up in your,
in your system.
That's why people fail.
Drug tests,
dummy.
Okay.
Um,
the,
the point being,
there's a big difference between coffee
that has been cultivated from a single
source and process.
The way this stuff's process
and we sell it cheaper
than he does.
If I'm getting poisoned by
Starbucks this whole time,
I really think people are,
I really do because I,
I drank some Starbucks this weekend
and I'm not talking shit on Starbucks.
I like Starbucks.
I drink it all the time.
Um,
I,
it doesn't,
it doesn't taste as good.
It doesn't feel as good.
My body feels different when I drink it.
I think I,
I think it's not their fault.
I think it's something that
people are just not that aware of.
And I think people have to be aware of it.
Now,
this is a legitimate issue with things
that you can't see that are on your food
that can really fuck you up.
You know?
I mean,
we,
we know there's poisons out there.
We know there's poison mushrooms.
I don't know why.
It's just surprise people that some
fungus that grows on some food is really
fucking shitty for you.
This is the tower seven of coffee.
It's not,
there's a lot of science
on mycotoxins says no,
it's no tower seven.
It's a fact.
If you go and look at mycotoxins on corn,
it's really kind of creepy.
Men.
Corn is fucking terrible for you,
man.
Well that means we're all poison
like corn syrup and all that shit.
You're probably getting a
little bit a negligible,
a little bit of a toxins
with that shit as well.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Well you can just Google it.
It's really interesting.
I might be wrong.
They might be blown with the science.
Might be all horseshit.
They might've made it up just to,
to go after the corn industry
because someone fucks someone's wife.
Fritos and Starbucks in up Lynn Tech.
But I do know,
yeah,
you can do that if you're really
down Fredo shake something.
We carry Blendtec blender is a perfect
example of something we just started
carrying because it's just awesome.
It's a good thing to have.
You know,
we,
we sell fitness equipment,
kettlebells,
battle ropes,
and there's an awesome extreme kettlebell
DVD video that we sell as well.
If,
you know,
if you an introduction to a high end,
um,
uh,
these,
um,
these crazy workouts people are putting
together like this one that we have from
Keith Weber,
it's,
it's really amazing.
It's a great workout.
It's about,
I think,
I mean I get,
I can't get through 45 minutes of it,
especially with a 50 pound kettle bell.
It will make you puke.
It's amazing.
It's a fantastic workout.
It's one of the best things to have where
all you have to do is just press play
and follow along with it.
Just go and we can't keep
these things in stock.
They're selling like crazy
for that very reason.
So it makes you puke.
So it's a way to work out and then
throw up sort of becoming baleen mic and
that's how you're getting fit.
Yeah.
You're getting Finn,
you growing up,
if you ever,
you've never worked out so hard.
You thrown out.
Never.
That sounds awful.
You've got to put any
time son sex go to on it.
Yeah,
he'll throw up after puke.
No,
I feel like puking sometimes after sex.
I bet you do because you can't
believe somebody fucked you.
I bet you just,
you just get in the bathroom
and you separate yourself.
It's more of like a heart
attack thing on it.com o n n.
I t use the code name Rogan and save
10% off any and all supplements.
And if you haven't been there for a while,
go and check it out cause we've
got a bunch of new crazy shit.
They're including killer
bee honey Himalayan salts.
I don't know if any that
stuff's really good for you,
but sounds bad ass.
All right,
you fucks.
Alex Honnold is here.
We're going to talk to this
young man about some crazy shit.
All right,
so strap in and prepare yourself.
Experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
Alex Honnold.
Greetings.
Hello.
Very nice to meet you in person and a
very nice to have you here on the show and
I'm super psyched that you decided to
come and join us because I watched one of
your videos,
I've seen several of them on the line
for folks who don't know Alex is what you
call a free solo climber.
Is that how you would describe it?
Yeah,
you could say that.
Um,
uh,
and he essentially climbs gigantic
scary mountains with no aid.
You,
you don't have ropes,
you just climate with
your hands and your feet.
And I mean occasionally,
occasionally,
well you in that car with ropes,
that's just special occasions,
you know,
but you do it a lot.
I mean there's a lot of
videos of you doing this.
You say an occasionally for
the average human being,
if they did something like that,
they would sit around the campfire
kids grandpa's I tell you about how he
climbed a mountain with his bare hands
and everybody would go on and on about
it.
Like it was a once in
a lifetime and insane,
you know,
death defying event.
How many times have you done it?
Well,
how many times did I
say three solo climbed?
Oh,
I mean,
it depends on how hard,
you know what I mean?
A free soul,
easy routes all the time.
But,
but you know,
the big hard ones that
you've seen videos of,
I mean,
that's a little more infrequent.
Have you ever had a close call?
Oh,
it all depends what you call it.
Close Call,
you know?
Um,
but no,
I haven't had any like
serious accidents or anything.
Well,
have you ever had a
moment where you're like,
oh shit like this,
this could be a problem?
Um,
well I mean certainly some
moments where you're like,
oh,
this could become a problem.
Um,
but never,
never like,
oh,
it's all going downhill and
it's about to come apart.
But have you ever gotten to a point,
I mean,
I assume your process is you first
climate with ropes to find out where your
route would be?
Yeah,
just generally.
Um,
I should,
do you know,
anything more climate?
Have you climbed in it?
No,
never climbed.
Okay.
Um,
because like within climbing,
you know,
there's more of a context for it.
But,
um,
the thing is,
I mean generally there's
already a root established.
You have like a little Topo,
you have a map that tells
you where your spot.
So people have already
done before you yeah.
On,
on all the,
on for the most part,
the things that I've sold it or like
established routes that people have done
before.
And for the most part
I've done them before too.
So I already kind of know this series
of movements that you had to go through
them once.
So the first time you went through it,
you follow a map of people
who've already been there.
Yeah,
generally.
Um,
I mean I have,
it's called onsite when you do something
without ever having done it before.
So I have like onsite solid,
big new routes before,
dude,
like,
just get sweaty talking to you.
I just want to tell
you right now for real,
my hands getting sweaty when
I'm thinking about this.
Um,
this,
we're watching a video right now if you
on 60 minutes and that was a established
route that you were climbing so that
that route was put up in the 60s I think.
Or maybe the 70s they start
doing this in the 60s.
Yeah.
But so when they establish it,
they use p tons and hammers and they're
like well their way up the mountain,
you know,
because that was kind
of the style of the day.
I think they did over multiple days and
then in the 70s it got done in a day for
the first time and then
you know what I mean?
It's just kind of the
gradual progression of style.
So climbing as a sport has
been around for a long time.
We'll coming as a sport is
like rooted back to albinism.
People like climbing in the Alps
and the 18 hundreds and all that.
I mean people are boys climbed a mountain.
I mean look at all the monks
and stuff in the Himalaya.
What attracted you to this?
I Dunno,
I just like climbing on things.
Why do you think
this has been since you were,
how old?
How old are you now?
I'm 27 now.
I've been climbing all the time,
like in the gym and stuff since I was 10.
I think it just,
it just,
it was attractive to you?
Yeah,
just,
I mean,
as a kid I love commentaries.
I love climbing buildings.
I'd like play on stuff,
you know,
climb the roof,
whatever.
Um,
and then,
uh,
my parents read about
this gym opening and sack,
like climbing gym.
So I went and started climbing inside.
What do your parents think about this?
While I was like surprisingly supportive,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean,
well I mean she just kind of trusts me
to do what I like to do and do it well
and you know,
make good decisions or whatever.
Yeah,
making good decisions.
That's a huge understatement.
It's one thing,
say,
you know,
sign.
If you want to get into
the insurance business,
you've got to make good decisions.
That's one thing.
Is anybody like in any course in
life has to like make good decisions?
Yes.
You are correct.
I mean,
cause if I was going out partying every,
every weekend,
you know,
I'd probably have almost
as high of a risk of death,
you know,
like driving drunk and all that
kind of stuff is what I'm doing.
You'll probably right.
I mean,
so it's like,
it's all just how you view
risk and reward rewarding.
It certainly is,
but that,
I mean,
that really is an understatement when
you're saying make them good decisions.
You climbing up these things,
like what is the tallest thing?
You've climbed a like 3000 feet minutes.
Well,
yeah,
but the difference between 3075 it
doesn't make that big difference as far as
death.
Yeah.
60 you're pretty much hosed.
But doesn't it feel like a
freak out when you're up?
To me,
the appeal is the,
is the bigness.
You know,
like I look at a huge face and I'm like,
that looks Rad.
You know,
if I look at it 60 foot face,
I'm kind of like,
no,
you know,
that looks okay.
But when you see a really huge,
impressive while you're like,
that's inspiring.
You know?
That's what I get psyched about.
Um,
do you like people watching you do this?
Uh,
not particularly.
And I've done very little soling
that's actually like live and watched,
you know.
So most of the videos that
you've seen and stuff for um,
you know,
repeated afterwards.
Well actually it's funny cause the one
that you're queuing right now is well so
semi live.
Um,
and the 60 minutes thing,
it was live cause they're like
a legitimate news organization.
They had to shoot the real thing.
Right.
Did it weird for you to
have people filming you?
That's the thing is that generally
when I film on projects like that,
um,
I do things that are like,
well within my abilities kind of
comfortable and easy and whatever.
So the 60 minutes thing,
even though it looks awesome
and it's really cool,
that's actually kind of like a
moderate route and it's not like,
you know,
it's not breaking new
ground for rock climbing.
I mean it never been sold before and it's,
and it's pretty hard,
but mostly I just chose something
that was aesthetic and like cool.
You know,
it was like good enough but
it's never been sold before.
Like,
that's the,
that's quite as well,
there aren't that many
people have that solar,
you know,
you're like not that
many folks are into it.
So you kind of have your pick of the,
pick the letter,
you know.
Well if there are that many folks into it,
how many of them aren't around anymore?
Well,
yeah,
it depends how you count.
Well,
what does this mean?
I can only think of one really
high end Solos to actually died.
So line really?
I think.
Yeah.
Only one.
Uh,
who was he a John Packer?
He was actually kind of like a,
you know,
childhood inspiration.
Like you spell his last name a,
Okay.
He,
uh,
he fell solely on things.
He was kind of older.
I mean,
he was maybe 50 or something and,
um,
he'd had a car accident and had
some like nerve damage and like,
you know,
who knows what actually happened?
Oh,
Jesus.
He,
maybe he broke a hole.
Maybe he just,
I don't know.
But like,
he'd had,
you know,
like back issues and things going
on because you'd had this like,
horrible car accident.
Oh Wow.
So on,
it's one of those things where
it's not like a clear cut,
like,
well I mean,
yeah,
I mean it is clear cut.
He fell off the mountain and he died.
But um,
so,
but you know,
you look at it cause he was,
he was by far the best of his generation
for like the eighties and early
nineties and actually
the 70s until the 90s,
basically.
Now when you see a guy and that's how
it ends for him and he's a free solo
climber,
do you look at that and say,
you know,
we know what everybody goes.
I mean,
that's kind of a cool way to do it.
Definitely not like that's
a cool way to do that.
That's horrible.
I mean,
I know,
I mean honestly,
he basically broke everything in his
body and he lay there for hours and died.
You know what I mean?
That's like a horrible,
horrible,
he didn't die instantly.
No,
he,
he was,
uh,
he was out at like a 60 foot
cliff by his house or whatever.
So he probably felt like 50 feet.
He broke everything in his body and he
bled out or I don't know what happened.
I mean,
it's like a horrible,
it's a horrible thing to happen,
but yeah,
I mean if you felt like 2000 feet,
yeah,
you would splat like,
you would just explode
like a bag of water.
But like,
but from 50,
it's like that's a pretty horrible,
yeah,
that sounds like a terrible way to go.
Yeah.
I mean it totally sucks,
but I mean,
the thing is,
you know,
he,
he lived his whole life doing
that kind of thing and you know,
he'd obviously confronted those kinds
of issues in his life and you know,
he,
he made his choice and that's,
that's how it worked out,
you know?
Wow.
How many people are doing it,
if you,
if you had to guess,
is it a,
well,
so that's,
earlier I said the difference between
high and so long and like recreational
stuff.
So if you're counting recreational,
just going out and climbing fun
routes after work or whatever,
they're tons of climbers that go Solon,
but,
um,
high end style,
like pushing it on hard,
you know,
hard,
hard routes like the kind of videos
that you're watching where you're like,
that looks insane.
Then there,
right now there's maybe a half dozen
dudes in the world that I think things
similar like that,
you know,
but you are known as the one who
does the most ridiculous routes.
Even the one who's known
as the guy well in,
in the u s right now anyway,
you know,
who else is doing this?
Where's this like popular?
There are a couple of dudes in Europe
who've done maybe not like at this moment
there and doing anything crazy,
but um,
that's certainly like recently
I've done really hard things.
Um,
you know,
I mean there's a,
there's a history of soloing
all around the world.
Wow.
It's,
this is completely new to me.
I mean,
I had seen like maybe,
you know,
randomly gone across videos on the
Internet of Peter Climbing things,
but I really never seen anything where
people would put climbing without ropes.
So when I first saw you doing it,
there's a rich tradition of it,
especially in California,
actually in southern California.
Um,
all the best climbers in the country
in the 70s came from Soco and they were
all,
they were called the stone masters.
And,
uh,
like Joshua tree,
you know,
which is just local has a,
like a huge history of Solon.
You know what I mean?
I grew up like hearing soling stories
and thinking it was cool and you know,
whatever.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's a total of like tradition of it,
but so do you make a living doing this?
I do now.
Yeah.
That's pretty,
pretty cool.
Wow.
And how did that happen?
Do you have sponsors?
Yeah,
that's how sponsors,
um,
sorta picked him up,
you know,
through the climbing community is I went
and the sponsors just give you money
and they pay you every month and just,
you just go climbing.
Yeah.
Yup.
Yeah,
they're really awesome.
Are there competitions or do you just
go wherever you want to go and people
follow you and the publicity helps them?
Is that how it works?
So there are competitions in climbing,
but um,
it's kind of like skiing or something
where it kind of subdivides into like
Olympic style competition scheme.
And then there's like big mountain type
dudes who make videos and just like go
rage in Alaska.
So I'm kind of one of those like big
mountain type dudes that just goes and
rages and makes videos and does whatever.
Like I don't do competitions.
It's kind of like two different supports.
Yeah,
you don't want to be rushed.
It doesn't seem like something
you would want to win.
How would you,
you know,
who would I compete with?
You know,
like nobody else even likes
to do this kind of stuff,
right?
Like that.
Doesn't that sound crazy though?
You're still talking about 300 million
people in this country and this may be
like five other dudes that
are doing what you're doing.
Well,
maybe five other than
the world and the world.
Okay.
And this country.
You're the only guy?
No,
there's like another dude,
he's a little older than me.
Who,
uh,
do you guys look at each other weird like,
yeah,
man.
Definitely not facing.
Um,
now there are a handful of
dudes in the states and I mean,
and things you never know
because so much is so long.
It just has to do with like motivation
because the actual technical difficulty
of the climbing isn't very high.
Like the thing that I did,
I'm on 60 minutes is actually
like a pretty easy route.
It's very moderate.
Um,
I mean like a lot of climbers who have
only been climbing a few years could
climb that difficulty level,
but they just would never
want to do it without a rope.
You know,
they don't have that motivation.
It'd be like,
I want to climb it huge face with no,
no protection.
Now when you,
you know,
you say that it's no big deal that you're,
you were the first person of free
solo something that is a big deal.
I mean,
you're just being humble.
Okay.
You are,
you're being humble.
You're crazy.
Listen to me.
Come on.
I'm older now.
I'm not saying you didn't
see him for doing that.
I'm saying,
you know,
your,
your point of view is
very self deprecating,
you know,
so you're your idea that that's not crazy
to be the first person to climb up it
in the known human race ropes.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's kind of fucking crazy kid,
but it seems more normal
when you do it all the time,
you know,
I'm sure.
But I'm just saying to a person like,
like me.
Yeah.
Um,
it's,
it's pretty impressive.
When you do you go up
something with ropes and say,
you know what,
I see enough spots.
Do you map it out in your head?
For sure.
So like for the 60 minutes when,
for example,
I'd climbed it a month before just to
like see if it was reasonable and I was
like,
okay,
I could definitely do this.
And then maybe 10 days before I climbed
it again with more like intention and
uh,
there are basically two hard parts on
it and the rest is sort of like filler,
you know,
like moderate climate,
like the type that I could easily
do first try whatever without no,
when you say hard parts
and you get to a place,
what makes it a hard part?
So the crack is like thinner,
so you have less of your finger inside
so you have to like pull harder and the
fee get bad and it gets steeper.
So the angle of the walls is steeper.
Um,
basically it just becomes more strenuous.
But so both of those two
sections where maybe,
you know,
10 movements long,
he said there may be like 15,
20 foot sections and I just have
to memorize like 10 or 15 moves.
So where I'm like,
okay.
And then I do my left hand to that little
thing and then I pull really hard and
then I raised my foot.
You know that.
So as you're going up this in a rope,
are you just visualizing going along
it or you actually fitting it with your
hands?
Yeah,
both.
I'm,
it's,
I'm climbing it and then,
um,
some of it I marched with chalk,
which is totally normal for comments too.
I put a little tick next to things.
So you remember like which
part of the crack is good.
And then I would memorize like,
okay,
this is the way to do it.
And then while I had the rope on,
I tried to a couple of different ways on
one part to see which felt more secure,
things like that.
And so do you take notes or do yes.
And then afterwards when
I was all done and uh,
you know,
that evening I like,
I drew out the sequences and
I have like a climate journal.
I keep track of things like that
and just make notes about life,
whatever.
And so I just mapped out the
sequences so I could remember it.
Well.
And would you ever publish that?
Well,
no,
it wouldn't make any sense to anybody.
Is a bunch of lines.
Do you know who would buy it?
That'd be dope.
Maybe a coffee table book.
I'll send you some lines
for a coffee table or maybe I,
I don't think I have enough volume
for that kind of thing either,
but maybe someday.
You know,
if I didn't,
dude,
I've really think there'll be a
dope coffee table book your map,
a little roots and stuff.
You're just musings on
life and a in a book for,
I think people would see and be like,
what the F no,
with photographs of the
actual mountain itself.
I think that would actually be,
I mean,
if it was,
yeah,
if it was interspersed with real photos,
like this is what it corresponds to.
Maybe.
Yeah.
I'm telling you,
man,
I don't even climb.
I would buy that shit,
dude.
Yeah.
I'm telling you.
That's a golden opportunity.
Jump on it.
Publishers find this young man.
Um,
have you ever been wrong?
Have you ever done like a route and said,
well,
I'm going to go solo it now and been like,
you know what,
this is,
this is an error.
I shouldn't have done this.
Uh,
not so much.
I've had a handful,
I mean,
I wouldn't call it an error,
but I've had a handful of times where
I've gone out to solo something without
pre-inspection where I'm just like,
oh,
I'm just going to go up
it and see how it goes.
And I go maybe halfway
up and I'm just like,
well,
I'm not feeling it.
And then I just calmed back down.
So do you,
um,
proceed if you know for sure that you
can't climb back down because you can't
always,
can you always climb back?
Generally?
I can climb back almost always,
almost in the end if I know that I'm
about to like pass the point where there's
like no,
no turning back then,
you know,
I sorta know that that's a
big deal and I think about it,
you know,
I think it through because on a 60
minutes piece that was actually something
that I,
yeah,
the narrator who was talking about like,
oh,
he can't correct.
Oh,
actually I saw,
I just had lunch with them.
He's the guy I was hanging
out with it and uh,
and um,
whatever Venice or wherever it was.
And,
um,
uh,
well I don't know.
So he was a big,
big climber in the 70s and he established
a lot of those routes and all that.
And I mean,
I know what he means that
it is harder to down climb,
but the thing is like nowadays,
I mean I don't know our practice down
climb and like I could down calm that,
you know,
for sure.
So I use just hating,
no,
he wasn't hating but like,
but from his perspective,
people don't down calm
and stuff like that.
Maybe he was a little bit of hyperbole.
Yeah,
a little bit,
but not,
I mean,
I'm pretty sure the route on 60 minutes.
Like if I absolutely had to,
I could have hiked to the top
and then down climb the thing,
you know,
it could have been like,
oh,
we're filming it in reverse,
you know,
shit,
it would be a lot less rad like that.
He'd be like,
that's fucking stupid,
that guy coming down the mountain,
you know?
But it's still just as scary,
but I see what you're saying.
Like it doesn't give
you that satisfaction.
Yeah,
exactly.
Climbing up the mountain,
you do a really hard hike and then you
freaking do extremely dangerous down
climb.
If you ever climb to the top
of something and then realize,
Holy Shit,
um,
I have to climb down
because I can't walk down.
There's no other way to
get down a little bit.
I've had a handful of
like epics like that.
But yeah,
a couple of my gnarliest experiences
have been a topping out routes that you
conventionally a repel down.
But since I don't have a robe on me,
I'm like,
okay,
I'll just pioneer some
kind of new descent.
And um,
so a couple of them involve,
do you know Zion National Park in Utah?
It's like a really Pretty River Canyon.
It's like sandstones.
It's,
it's beautiful.
But um,
it's like a thousand foot wall.
And then the rim of the Canyon is like
2000 feet above it and it's a really,
really steep sandstone.
And normally you would climb a thousand
feet and then repelled back down and be
like,
oh,
sweet.
So I climbed the thousand foot wall and
then I'm up there and it's like 2000
feet are really steep and it was all
covered in like snow or it sorta like
consolidated hail is all messed up.
Oh,
super hard to scramble and you know,
cause they're like roads anyway.
And then it started snowing
as soon as I hop out.
And so I was like clawing my way up this
hail in like this driving blizzard and
I it actually,
and then that blizzard
while you were up there.
Yeah.
Well,
so the day that I decided to do,
I was,
I was a little angst for and I was like,
I'm going to do this goddammit and
hold it at the time is like last,
this is the last February a year ago.
But um,
but uh,
so the forecast that there is going to
start snowing at noon and I was like,
well,
you know,
I'll finish by then.
So I finished it.
I finished at like 1130.
It started snowing right
on schedule and I was like,
oh no problem.
I'll hike off.
The thing is,
even once I made it to the rim,
which took me forever and it was,
I was getting pretty wet and pretty
cold and it was kind of messed up and
visibility was so low,
I was worried about getting lost.
And then once you're up on the top,
it's just a big plateau.
And I was hoping to hit this one trail
that it was like a 10 mile hike on the
trail back around to get back to the car.
And uh,
even though it's all just a field of snow
and like whiteout blizzard style and I
was just running along in
my climbing shoes like,
God,
I Hope I can find something.
But miraculously I found the trail and
made it all the way out and there's no
problem.
Oh Shit.
But as you apply yourself and all
these experiences he has pretty at,
that was a satellite phone?
No,
nothing.
Satellite phone.
Why would I have a satellite phone?
The climate at the top of a mountain.
No,
I mean,
well the,
the thing with that though is like,
so the whole time I did,
I was like,
this is hardcore.
You know,
and then as soon as I was back at the car,
I was like,
well,
it's like noon.
I had a very eventful morning,
but like,
it doesn't even feel like a full day,
you know what I mean?
The whole thing,
like the whole thing like feels
surreal because you're like,
did I just do that?
Like,
that was weird.
You only took a few hours
where you're just like,
whoa.
Wow.
Was that the most harrowing
experience you've ever been on?
No.
For sure.
No,
but it was,
but it for sure.
What was it?
Very invigorating morning,
you know,
what is the most hair raising
experience you've ever had?
I,
I dunno,
I mean,
it depends what you call her,
raising.
What's the most difficult
climb you've ever done?
I Dunno.
Um,
I mean,
again,
you know,
I need like tighter definitions.
Okay.
Um,
has there ever been a climb
that you did where you,
you realize like,
wow,
that might have been the most strenuous,
the hardest I've ever had to work?
Yeah.
I have not yet.
Shit,
my pants docker,
I'm close,
but I'm so for free soloing maybe.
Um,
the first time I free soloed half to him,
which was in 2008.
I think at the time.
I think it was maybe a
little bit much for me.
You know,
like when I finished I was like,
Ooh,
maybe not that I like got away with it,
but that's kind of the feeling,
you know,
you get to the top and you're like,
Whoa,
we are for sure.
I was like,
yeah,
because the one of the hardest and least
secure parts of the whole climb is up
at the very top.
So you're at like the
top of a 2000 foot wall.
And um,
and it took me like two 50
to climb the whole route.
So I was probably up there at two
35 at this like super hard part.
I'm already kind of frazzled and you know,
because you've been really focused
for like two and a half hours,
like trying really hard and you're just
getting a little tired and whatever,
and then you get to the hardest
part that's also the least secure.
It's a really insecure style.
It's like they're no actual
holds to hold on to it.
It's just like a bald slab that,
and you just wait your feet and so,
uh,
you just have to eat your feet.
What do you mean means like,
so you're wearing really
tight climbing shoes.
It's like really precise edges
on them and you basically just,
it'd be like if you took that brick wall
and you like leaned it back and made it
a little smoother and then all you can
do is stand on the little edges of the
bricks,
you know,
actually,
well if you tilt it it
back to like 87 degrees.
You could probably walk up that wall
with no hands but just the edges,
you know.
But it would chill around about that.
You would look at this wall
and start thinking about roots.
Well you see a wall and look
for areas I love little bit,
a little bit.
Is there a difference between that guy
who does your type of stuff like mountain
climbing stuff and those crazy
dudes or climb buildings?
No,
I mean he's still just climbing stuff.
Deep practice on the floor.
Do you like practice
climbing on the floor?
Would that be called laying down?
I mean like,
like,
like would Brian shut the fuck up?
I,
I do push back.
How do you,
uh,
do you have like a,
a strength or conditioning program
that you did a bunch of us do a lot of,
a little bit when I'm motivated.
Like I did a bunch of planks this morning,
but I don't know.
Does it help your climbing?
I Dunno,
that's the,
that's the thing.
But I mean it makes my
core is wrong if you're,
if you're climbing has done right.
How much of it actually does
involve physical strength?
A fair,
um,
a fair amount,
fair amount.
Eventually.
The thing you said what I was
just talking about a slab,
you know,
that's all about technique and precision
with footwork and all that kind of
thing.
That's all mental and,
and I mean you have to have
toned calves or whatever,
but um,
but then if you tip a wall back the
other way and you're climbing out,
so I'm kind of like
overhanging ceiling then.
I mean,
it really does come down to
having strong arms and strong.
Yeah.
I mean in general,
for a recreational climber,
you should be using your feet and you
should be using good technique and you
should keep your weight over your legs.
But,
um,
but when you get into
really high end climbing,
it's like,
um,
you know,
you just gotta be able
to pull really hard too.
I saw a video or a photograph
of you holding onto some
pillars or some beams and
doing chin.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Can you do that?
You really can.
You can work as a photo of it.
I mean if the beacon actually Ergonomic
flop and move and not just hold there.
Yeah,
I was,
yeah,
I could do like two pull
ups on those BMC for,
I'd fall over.
I mean it was really hard
for me to hold on to them.
Yeah.
I would imagine though.
But that's gotta be pretty rare
that someone can even do it too.
Well,
but I mean there are plenty of dudes
who were a lot stronger and that kind of
thing that I am is that uh,
cause I've heard crazy stories about these
free solo climber is being able to do
chin ups with one finger and a thing.
You can do that.
Um,
right now I could probably do two,
two fingers.
When I was a kid I could do like a one
finger one on I think not in to one
finger,
one arm,
Chin up.
Yeah.
I mean hanging off like a slang,
you know,
like a little piece of rope or something.
That's the photo of you hanging in there.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Classic that Ah,
that chalk stuff's huge,
Huh?
Well,
yeah.
I mean the same as gymnast and
everything keeps your hands dry.
Yeah.
You do you ever Solo
something without chalk?
You look at it and like I'm
going to need chalk for that.
Uh,
no.
You pretty much always take a chalk bag
unless it's like real easy and I'm just
scrambling up it.
Have you ever lost a chalk bag?
I have actually.
It's,
if it's funny you ask this last summer,
like one of the biggest things
that I've done solving the triple,
which was like climbing in three
big faces and he's 17 in a day.
Um,
the second thing that I
climbed was El Capitan,
just like a 3000 foot face.
And I climbed it through
the night and accident.
I forgot my chalk bag at
the bottom and I was like,
God,
yeah.
And so when I was all
ready to start climbing,
I was like,
ah,
damn it,
you know?
And actually it was kind of messed up
cause the root was kind of wet because it
rained a lot the day before.
And so it's the kind of
thing where you like,
you really want to chalk bag.
But um,
I was like,
well bummer.
You know,
and then I did the first 800 feet
and then I actually passed a party.
He was sleeping on the route because
most people climbing over like four days.
What?
Yeah.
Well I mean a 3000 foot faces.
So you've,
you saw a guy that was like camped out
on one of those crazy outcropping tents.
Yeah,
that was,
yeah,
they were actually,
it was,
so it's kind of a standard ledge.
It's like where people
generally camp on the roads of,
well it's like the size
of half this table,
you know what I mean?
So it's like,
but so there were two parties,
the two guys,
and they were all camped on it and so
they each had their little tents that
you're talking about.
So that,
you know,
cause there's not much room,
so it's half the size of this
table and everybody's on it.
And the big party.
Yeah.
But that's pretty comfortable
converted hanging on a vertical face,
you know?
Right.
You're like,
oh sweet,
I can stand,
you can take off your harness if you want,
whatever.
Anyway though,
it's our past,
these dudes in the middle of the night,
you were camping there and the guy
gave me a chalk bag and I was like,
oh wow.
So then when I got to the top,
I tied out after this little tree,
so then he got it back later.
So,
uh,
that's pretty cool.
So it's like,
so you just kept going,
you climbed the,
the whole thing.
And once you got the chalk bag,
you're like,
then it was game on,
you know?
Oh my God,
what did they say to you when you're like,
I forgot my chalk.
We like what the fuck man.
Little bit.
I think they were like,
Huh?
The fact that they were up
there for like five days,
you know,
and that this dude climbs
through and he's like,
excuse me,
do you have any chalk?
And they were like,
what the fuck is this guy going know?
But I actually saw,
I met that guy again.
I think that's his favorite story
because I've probably met like half the
climbers on the west coast.
You're like,
hey you,
you met my buddy Steve.
He gave me,
you gave him this chalk bag,
whatever gave you his chalk bag.
I've met like a dozen
people who were like,
Hey,
I met this guy that,
you know,
I think there are a pretty sight,
just cause it's a funny story.
Oh,
it's a very funny story.
It's a very crazy story though,
man.
Just your reality is your reality to you.
It's just normal.
Yeah.
Cause,
I mean that's,
that's normal.
But I'm serious.
I'm talking to you.
My hands are sweaty.
I get sweaty,
I think about high heights and
I get like the butterfly thing.
I could think about it being like high up,
I can do that.
I freak myself out.
Do you look at like when you're at a
building and so do you think are in
climates pitch do you to
look at things like that?
I don't know.
I mean,
buildings I do look at and I'm like,
oh that'd be rad except you get arrested.
So I kind of nipped that in the bud,
you know?
But with rocks for sure.
I mean you see some things,
you just,
you're like,
that looks red and I'd love to climb that.
Two climbers ever do things
like that for publicity stunts.
Like know that they're going to get
arrested but just climb something.
Anyone?
Yeah.
I mean surely you've heard of,
I don't want her bear the Alhambra bear,
the French solos guy who did the New
York Times building and it's like climbed
pretty much every skyscraper in the world.
You know what?
Probably peripherally.
I've heard of that guy,
but I've never talked to you when you
talking about dude Solon and skyscrapers,
he's the only dude long skyscrapers.
Yeah.
Like any skyscraper you've
heard of being solid.
It's that guy.
And they don't lock them up for one.
Well,
no,
I mean he's been arrested
and tons of times,
like you talked that you talked
about some building in Japan.
He got punched in the
face by a security guard.
You know,
he's had all kinds of weird stories.
But um,
I met him in Poland at this film
festival thing last year and I was like,
oh that's,
it's great to meet him actually because
he was like a really good climber,
like in the eighties and nineties and
then he sort of transitioned into,
like,
he,
he doesn't even call
himself a climber anymore.
He's just like,
oh,
you know,
just climb buildings.
It's fun.
Whatever.
It's like as a job.
But so does he sell books or does dude,
yeah,
he does like speaking stuff.
Apparently books like some
of the buildings that he
gets paid for it because you
know,
like in the Middle East they like unveil
like the biggest building in the world
or whatever and then they pay
him to climate and you know,
whenever,
you know,
there was a guy,
uh,
I don't know if it was him,
but someone was doing something recently.
It was on the news,
I just slipped was walking through an
airport or something and the guy had
suction cups and it's climbing
up some fucking night.
Tom Cruise in mission impossible.
I don't think so.
I think it was an actual real person.
Yeah.
Some guy he didn't think
that should exist in,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh it does.
Oh yeah.
He was climbing up a glass building
and he was using suction cups.
You can,
yeah,
you can actually do it
seems like it'd be scary.
Yeah,
it was real scary.
He was also,
one time it was another video
of another building and get out.
He was in a crack like this,
like it was like a v crack going smaller
as it got away from him and he was
climbing the wall that way.
It just pressing up against
the wall and climbing that way.
There's probably a set standard,
like a standard technique.
Yeah,
for sure.
Do you ever get yourself in a situation
like that where that's how you're
climbing,
you're pressing up against the wall and
that's actually a lot easier probably
than it might look to you really.
Probably.
I mean,
generally when you're doing any kind of
counter pressure type stuff like that,
like pushing two sides,
I mean,
you're using your whole body as
opposed to just your fingers.
Right?
So I mean it's not that,
not that strenuous,
depending on how,
what the angle is and everything.
My God.
But we know how little kids loved to
like chimney up like doorframes were
hallways or whatever.
Yes.
You know where you put your backhands
one side of your feet together.
I mean,
that's pretty,
pretty stable and you know,
it's easy to do.
You know,
what is that?
Here's the guy saying he's got the,
Oh yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
That line we're bear does
he has suction cups up?
No,
not in this one.
But that's actually quite easy.
I mean he,
he can go now hands right,
right there.
You know,
so then when he has to do the
movements in between levels,
this is insane.
You think this looks easy?
Yeah.
But yeah,
I mean not that I'm
diminishing as accomplishment,
but like,
but that particular like feet of
climbing does not look hard at all.
You should be an,
you should become a tagger.
You'd be like the ultimate tagger but
that goes back to what not when you got
arrested,
you know,
you dress up as Spiderman or some bitch.
Yeah,
exactly.
Put that
totally like Carrie
paint with you and stuff.
So knowing,
fuck up your whole balance thing.
Yeah,
exactly right.
It's just a sticker called
bucket hanging off me.
Alan Bro Bear Guy.
He started off doing the regular
climbing and just decided this,
no money in this shit.
Actually,
I think part of it was that,
um,
he had a couple of kind of terrible ground
falls where like he felt so alone and
it got all messed up
like different things.
And so,
um,
I think he now has like a summer
restricted range of motion.
I can't move his arms in certain ways.
And so,
um,
so,
so long on rock is kind of out of the
question a little bit because rock
requires like real rock requires such
a diverse range of movements cause you
never know like where the holes are
going to be or what direction they'll be
facing.
Where's buildings are extremely uniform.
Right.
But you know,
say like with a building,
you know,
he can look at it and be like,
okay,
I'm going to be like that
little clip you just saw.
He did that exact same movement over and
over for a thousand feet or however big
that building is.
So Tito,
so this is like,
I guess it's just another example,
something
where if you don't know how to do it,
it looks impossible.
I should know that by now.
Is it every guest that
you have on like that,
you know,
where you're like astrophysics?
Yeah.
Crazy.
Like actually it's real
boring study physics.
Astrophysics is boring.
That hasn't,
but I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It becomes commonplace.
They didn't come from what you do
and then they should or something.
They're like,
yeah,
punch people in the face.
Well,
I don't really hit him that much.
Most of what I do is Jujitsu these days.
So you throw them into a wall.
It's the strangle him.
Why Mars and stuff.
Have you ever climbed during a earthquake?
Like,
or is that a fear of yours?
Like having like the big
earthquake while you're there?
Fuck a fat one.
Yeah.
But see a mountain driving
over a bridge and the
same,
yeah,
but you were in a car
and it's like a movie.
The car might hit the water and then
you can open up a window and you can get
out.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
but,
but the,
the connection between the Lick,
looking at people doing martial arts,
it,
it totally makes sense to me that,
you know what I mean?
Like I watch a video of an ICO master
or something like throwing people around
the word around the room.
And that was something son,
most of,
yeah,
most of that's horse shit.
All right.
Well I can either read was read a martial
art that really works if the other
person doesn't know anything or if you
have no idea what this guy doing or if
you're cooperating.
And that's what a lot of it is.
The videos the guys running at you
and he's committing to a very specific
technique and you're
throwing them on the ground,
but you never see that
applied in like a UFC match.
He very rarely you'll see some of
the principles of misdirection and
manipulating bodies and like
throwing bottles with leverage,
but the way you see it in
like in a kito demonstration.
But Shit never happens in the real world.
It just doesn't,
it's,
it's kind of,
there's a lot of that leftover from,
there was a time where martial arts had
like a great mysticism attached to it,
but because of the UFC,
because of mixed martial arts competition,
it's become much more pragmatic and now
they really understand what works and
what doesn't work.
So I,
Kido is one of those martial arts.
It has some practical application,
but as a lot of fuckery there's a lot
of shit that just doesn't work or apply
that mindset to climbing.
I'm sure.
Sure.
Yeah.
I have friends that watch like a
martial arts thing on television.
Like fuck that guy.
Just do that.
And like that's a wheel kick.
That's like standard technique,
you know,
that's how you looking at this flag and
that guy is on those two buildings or
those two sides.
Like that's uniform.
That's a hanger that's,
he does nothing to do.
Everyone's got their thing.
You know that some people don't have
their things so they should find their
thing.
They should knit,
you know,
they should start a garden.
Like everybody can do something.
Everybody should have a thing though.
I completely agree.
I had a friend who was
getting divorced and uh,
but what,
that's one of the things he said.
He said,
uh,
he goes to five,
find another woman.
He goes,
I swear to God I'm going to find
someone who likes something.
He goes anything fucking taller
and actually said rock climbing,
fucking rock climbing.
He was so mad cause he had did well he,
you know,
he married someone who
was a little bit vapid.
It was a fascinating there you really
need something to get him out of bed and
not just to get you out of bed though.
Just to make it fun where
you gotta to be fired up,
you know,
to like to make like interesting.
Yeah.
And it affects your health too.
It really does.
It affects how you feel.
It affects site.
If you have something
you really love to do,
if there's anything I could ever tell
anybody that's out there that's young,
that's like got a lot of people that
are telling them to take a safe route.
Actually there are no young people
listening to this young people.
I hope.
I hope there are like eight
to 14 is our [inaudible].
We go for 12 year olds.
12 year olds are more malleable.
That's fair.
All right.
Oh man,
it's on the Internet.
I'm sure there's fucking
12 year olds listening.
I get emails from 16
year olds all the time.
Like the curse with kids.
You know why it's just a word.
Second year olds are old enough.
That's that sweet.
I feel I feel bad.
A little kid,
but you shouldn't because they're going
to say it when they become adults.
It's crazy.
You should.
Everybody should say fuck
that way for a little bit.
You don't think?
No.
I say keep using it,
but use it in moderation.
No one to use it.
It's like,
like comedians.
When comedians used the word fuck too
many times you overflow you route.
It ruins the impact of the word,
but when you don't use it that
often and then you use it,
boom,
it works.
My point is there's nothing
wrong with little kids saying,
fuck it's,
it's adorable.
Didn't we've watched that movie.
What the fuck was that
movie with Nicholas Cage?
The a kick ass kick ass little
girl calls over the cons.
It's beautiful.
There's nothing wrong with that man.
We're,
we're silly people with magic words,
but if there's anything that you can,
that young people can hear
that can benefit them,
the big one is do what you're drawn to.
Whatever you're drawn to.
Go to that.
Just find something you love to do
because your life will be different than
someone who just works because we could
all get by just working and have hobbies
and you know,
and have family and friends that keep
us entertained and have people at work
that we enjoy being around so
we can have a good time working.
I'm not saying you don't have a good
life if you're a person who works.
When I'm saying is if you have the
choice and you do when you're young,
you do.
When you don't have commitments,
you don't have a mortgage,
you don't have a family.
Go do what you fucking love.
Go there,
go get,
find whatever it is because
you're a perfect example of that.
What you do would make me shit
my pants every day of the week.
I have no desire.
I don't,
I don't have her look at mountains.
I go,
fuck man,
I need to climb that shit.
Never.
It's not in me.
It doesn't,
it doesn't appeal to me.
I look over the edge of building.
It's like,
oh well when I fucking run away and hide,
I am so not into that.
But I love the fact that you are,
you know,
I'd love the fact that people are so
different that it's whatever it is,
or ones and Zeros inside of your make.
You look at a tree and
won a fucking climate.
I don't know what that is,
but I think it's awesome.
You know,
it's a,
it's,
it's shocking and it's weird,
but it's awesome.
And it's a perfect example
of that principle in action.
You've always been drawn to climbing.
You climb and look at you.
You're happy bastard.
That's what I was saying,
that my family's always been
surprisingly supportive,
you know,
because I think my mom sort of
values exactly what you're saying.
And she's like,
that's what he loves to do.
He's doing it.
He's working hard at it,
doing it well,
like,
you know,
can't do any better than none.
You got a cool mom.
That's,
if everybody had a mom like that,
we would be a better world.
Yeah.
Do you have any fears?
Like are you scared of Shit Shits?
Is there anything like that?
Yeah,
no,
nothing.
Nothing crazy.
You know,
my friend's girlfriend has
a Arachnophobia like legit,
like if you say spider around her,
just say the word spider.
Her throat starts to close up.
Really?
She can't talk.
She freaks out.
You know who it is.
She was there the other day,
girl.
Oh,
we're watching spider.
Yeah.
You remember that?
You say the word spider around her who
are her throat starts to close La for no
reason.
Kind of weird.
Yeah.
And she has no idea.
She has no life experience with a spider.
There's never been any limitations and
those spite them all stay shoes and
molested by a tarantula.
She was a baby,
you know?
I mean would it probably was,
was I bet someone in
her chain of ancestry,
this is just totally
unscientific theory by me.
Like a daddy long leg.
I have this idea of genetic
memory and it's a shit,
you know,
I'm not a scientist so I
shouldn't even be talking here,
but I'm gonna say it anyway
cause it's just a thought.
The idea is that when people
have like reincarnations,
you know,
when,
people say like,
Oh,
uh,
I'm uh,
you know,
a soldier that lived in the 16 hundreds
and I've been reincarnated and you know,
I can tell you about the boat that I was
on that got sunk by the British troop.
You know,
when,
when people have those stories,
I really wonder whether or not sperm,
whether or not genetics,
whether or not you're,
you're a bar.
Like when,
when a person makes another person,
how much information is
actually getting to that kid.
It might be like all a lot
more than we have access to.
And it might very well be that
when you are a person who has,
you know,
who many macs of thousands
of traceable generations,
that all of that information of all
those people's lives might be somehow
another encoded in our DNA.
So in her past,
somewhere on the,
along that chain of life,
someone had a fucking horrific experience
with a spider and maybe almost died
and shit.
Their pants,
every time they see spiders
and some hundred that wacky
gene think finds its way
into her little personality toolbox.
And now you say spider around
her and her throat closes shut.
I mean this makes sense to me.
I mean obviously I know
nothing about genetics.
Does that mean you can
get raped and feel that?
But that will go away,
you know?
Okay.
Where,
where are the instincts come from?
Them.
Why?
Why do we have instincts?
Why do little,
why are they afraid of monsters
if they live in cities?
Why is everybody afraid
of things with big teeth?
It's in the dark.
I'll tell you why.
Because at one point in time we
used to be hunted by leopards.
Okay.
We would go out of our tents at night,
we'd get fucked up,
you know,
cause we were a little monkey people
and that shit is still in our head.
We're still terrified of
monsters in the night.
And I think that's a genetic thing.
I think there's certain instincts that
humans have that are relayed through
generation after generation of
experience after experience.
It only makes sense that
somehow or another that code,
these new DNA is different
than personal experience.
Well,
I think it's not because memes,
they know that racism can be
transferred through genetics.
They,
there's direct evidence that people
who do not have exposure to racism,
but their parents were racist and they
were adopted or more inclined to become
racist or have racist ideology,
et Cetera.
So not only did some,
some study on memes where
they had a identical twins,
I watched some documentary on the,
the,
the concept of cultural genes basically.
It's not,
not just its ideas period.
And the,
the,
the concept is that there's a certain
amount of things that you learn in life
that's related to your children.
And that's one of the reasons why
children of musical people become very
musical.
It's like,
it's very common that people
have children and their children,
not just because it's the
environment they grow up in,
but they show like an instant proclivity
towards some sort of a thing that you
were very good at that wouldn't have
to do with your physical genetics.
As we think of it as firms as you know,
body type and you know,
athleticism and things along those lines,
which we've already assumed
transfer on and we know transfer on.
But I think there's,
there's also life experience and
mental things that transfer on her.
You know,
it doesn't mean that you're going to
be racist because your dad was racist
because we know that's not the case with
people that grew up with a racist dad.
You know,
I have a friend whose dad was dad just
can't not be racist no matter what it is
in the news.
It means like Archie bunker type dude.
You know what's kind of funny,
but he's just so racist.
My friend,
like as liberal as they come,
it just has no inclination towards any
sort of judgment of anybody and it's
probably just his response to
growing up with this idiot.
You know,
these sort of figured out how dumb it is.
he's rebounded from it,
which is pretty common with people.
But if he hadn't been around that guy
and been in different environments,
I mean who knows how much
of it is nature and nurture.
But the concept is that some of it is
being transmitted through information,
through genetics.
I think it makes sense.
So this poor bitch some like somebody
got checked by a spider and our past,
maybe I might be right.
It makes sense.
What's so funny?
So like her great,
great,
great grandmother was like,
Hi once in a little spider biters.
You're like,
oh,
oh
I know a girl who got bit by a fucking
Brown Breck loose in her pussy.
Oh it was in her underwear.
She pulled her underwear.
I didn't know the spiders in there.
There's spider bit.
Her fucking pussy and a brown recluse
is the most horrific spider in North
America.
In fact,
it doesn't just doesn't poison you.
It literally turns your flesh dead flesh.
Yeah.
What happened to her?
She,
her pussy died.
Ah,
can you imagine this?
You still have a pussy.
Is it just a whole,
it's dead.
It died.
Did a really I pussy.
That's tragic.
I don't know the extent of the damage,
but I have never seen a brown
recluse bite that didn't do so.
I don't know how quickly
she got to the doctor.
But essentially the toxins kills all the
flesh around it to the point where you
have to carve it out.
It's like a big dead holds.
We discussed her.
Yeah.
So she has a hole in her whole,
Oh,
it's probably don't even say it.
Don't say you son of a bitch.
They um,
they did do something.
Um,
with the,
Oh,
Jeremy Horn,
one of the MMA fighters.
He had a,
um,
a brown recluse sting on
his leg and he had like,
it was like a golf ball holes crazy.
He had like this giant hole that had
just eaten through his leg and he had to
like keep gauze in it and everything
that's happened to a lot of guys.
These fucking brown reckless
is the climb in your shoes,
you know,
and then you just put your shoe on and
it'll sting you and your foot's jacked.
Their port of Scorpion out
of my shoe and you send me,
did you boy,
he didn't know it was in there.
No,
I mean,
oh,
you miss it before you put your shoe on.
I was going to put my shoe on
and poured out of Scorpion.
It was like,
Huh?
Wow.
Yeah.
How,
how poisonous or scorpions,
there's different models around
rectories probably would have been fine.
Some of them,
some of them fuck you up and
some of them just hurt real bad.
Right?
Like a beast.
And I've heard the little
ones are like real poisonous,
but I think it's just painful.
It's not like you're going to die.
Okay.
But we had,
we used them on fear factor
of we use the big giant ones,
which are really not that bad,
which I think aren't as bad.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy.
But they fuck you up.
It's counterintuitive.
Yeah.
They look horrific.
Those big black here,
it looks so evil,
but just intimidating.
What is fear factor?
Fear factor.
Factor.
Yeah.
You were the,
what did you do with that?
You're the host or something as the host.
What does that mean?
You just told people that
are going to get messed up by
like,
do you spend all your time
climbing trees and shit?
We didn't never have like a TV and stuff,
you know,
he's one of those things.
I like heard of it.
I've never had a teacher.
We had a TV but it was like in my parents'
room and we damn cable and we didn't,
you know,
I don't know.
I didn't see that much TV.
Wow.
Um,
fear factor was a game show and it was um,
people got like torture.
No,
they had to do things that
were difficult to like,
sometimes they would have
to cars per building.
Sometimes they would get stung by a
scorpion so that if you want bugs or
drinking or they can say no for real,
like bull semen or like red boy you mean?
Yeah.
Red Bull is no twice and it was donkey.
Oh yeah,
they had a drink waiting for Krill.
Yeah.
That's what he got the show
canceled that got the show cancel.
That's where they drew the line.
I know.
Shit.
Capital letter e,
capital n,
u f.
F.
E.
Nef drink.
Would you drink a pitcher of donkey come
for the chance to win $50,000 not for
the chores.
You were definitely getting 50 grand.
You would do it maybe.
I mean,
yeah,
maybe it's not that big a deal.
I never understood about those shows.
Is that like if you had to
do any of those things,
it can't be that bad to do,
but if you're just doing
it for shits and giggles,
like why would you ever just let
yourself get stung by Scorpions for fun?
You know,
this was warming curdled like
there was a top layer was,
no,
that was it.
Yeah,
it was a,
it actually was everything
had to be a sanitizer.
Yeah.
Temperature controlled to
make sure it didn't curve.
They show Tim Harden up.
Was there a yellow oil on the top of it
that this kind of like sat there in the
middle oil?
Like it seems pretty
what's wrong with you?
Calm your comes broken too
much Starbucks or whatever.
Yeah.
Mycotoxins pool.
I bet if you took a syringe and stuck it
in that yellow stuff and pulled it out
to be pure,
mycotoxins were DMT.
That's your con.
It's just all pure pure toxin.
Can you get,
can you extract TMT from com?
Um,
I dunno.
I don't know what the exact content to
come on your extra talkative today with
dumb shit.
This is something
happening over the weekend.
Did you hit your head?
Well,
you can extract it from any,
did you hit your head?
No.
You could distract from humans and plants.
Come see comments.
Can you get brain cells from come?
No,
you can't.
Calm can make a brain cell by combining
with a woman's ag and making a baby.
But you don't get brain
cells out of comedy.
Silly Bitch.
Hmm?
Do you get pretty standard?
This is the podcast that
people listen to you.
You understand that?
Are you aware that concept?
How do you extract the empty from Creston?
Okay,
stop.
This is too dumb.
It's too dumb.
Can't do this.
See what I have to deal with every day.
You know what?
That's a kid who grows
up with nothing but TV.
No parents,
they put them in front of the fucking
teeth and they never answered a question
once they broke him.
Hello.
Tragedy,
tragedy for you because you
never been on the show before.
You didn't know what you're expecting.
Guy Thought I was going to come on
here and some regular 60 minutes tape
respecting 60 minutes that
are super professionals
having 60 minutes.
Find out about you.
Uh,
the producer was like an amateur
climber and he just Kinda Kinda into it.
Oh Wow.
So it was his idea.
Yeah.
And actually you had to pitch
it a bunch of times too.
He said,
cause uh,
you know,
he pitched it and they were like,
well,
that sounds retarded and sorry,
pitched again.
And they're like,
no,
like,
who cares about climbing?
You know?
And then he said that finally he,
uh,
he cut himself his own little highlight
reel type deal from stuff off the
Internet and whatever.
And um,
and then showed it to his boss is like,
look,
it's this.
And they were like,
Oh yeah,
let's do that.
Visually it's,
so that's the thing.
That's the thing.
But if you just,
if you just tell though,
there's this kid that basically
homeless that rock climbs a lot,
you know,
they're like,
that sounds stupid,
you know.
How did you feed yourself when,
before the 60 minutes thing?
Before you answer Paul.
I mean,
I had sponsored for 60 minutes.
It actually 60 minutes and even
changed my whole sponsorship scene.
I already had all the climate stuff.
Yeah.
Because you know,
the 60 minutes just catapulted
me into like the mainstream.
But I mean,
I've,
I've been a pretty good climate
for like years before that,
you know?
So how did people find out
about you before they just,
you just start climbing,
word of mouth,
whatever,
like climbing magazines.
It's such a small community.
Yeah,
it's a fairly small community.
What were you doing
for a living back then?
Well,
so for a couple of years,
um,
so I dropped out of college after
one year I was going to UC Berkeley.
Do Engineering.
There's no climbing in this room.
Yeah.
I'm like,
yeah,
get me out of here.
I was like,
this is kind of,
I wasn't super fired up on
it for engineering would,
what was the,
the idea that was,
I don't know,
it was going to do civil engineering,
like build big structures or something.
I don't know.
I wasn't like super
excited about it though.
And then,
uh,
and then I kind of stopped and then I
went climbing for a while and so for the,
like I spent a couple of years just kind
of road trip and in climbing and then I
had sponsors and I did it more,
you know,
becoming more and more.
When you first left college,
what did you do?
Did you get part time jobs
and just climb everywhere?
Ads?
Well,
so it's slightly more complicated,
but,
so,
um,
my dad died like the summer
before I stopped going to college.
Well,
actually,
so first off I got invited to youth,
nationals,
whatever.
So I'm like,
uh,
like the Youth World Cup type thing
because I did well at US nationals.
And so,
um,
it gave me an excuse to be like,
I'm going to take the next semester
off and just like go to Europe,
do this youth camp and then,
uh,
and then travel Europe and climate bit,
you know,
so I was like,
well,
I'm going to take next semester off.
And then,
um,
and then my dad died that summer.
And so,
you know,
I was taking the semester off and then
he left enough money for my sister and I
finished school,
like life insurance,
you know,
for us both to finish college.
And,
um,
and so I went to Europe,
you know,
did this whole comp,
didn't do very well,
whatever,
but um,
and then just never went back to college.
And then you use the life insurance to
like travel and climb for a couple of
years.
Wow.
Yeah.
So cool.
So when you first started doing that,
did you ever believe that you could
get to a 0.1 day where you'd be a
professional he'd make,
I didn't even know.
I didn't even know there
were professional climbers.
You know,
it'd be like,
it's such a niche little thing.
I mean all I knew is that I loved going
climbing and that there wasn't anything
else that I'd rather be doing and that
I wasn't super fired up on school.
And so I was just like,
well I'm just going to go on a road trip.
The road trip is kind of like
a classic climbing thing.
Everybody goes on the road trip and just
travels and climbs and follows the good
weather.
And so I just did that for a few years.
And then that's just like
a climber community thing.
Yeah.
A lot of like most
climbers do that basically.
Cause you kind of have to,
because you have to,
you have to be at the different
rocks in different places,
in good weather.
So I mean,
you have to constantly move,
but wow.
So while you're doing this,
you just thinking,
Hey,
I've,
I just,
I've got the time to do this now.
I'm enjoying doing this.
Now let's just do it
cause I want to do it.
Yeah.
Basically.
I mean,
you know,
at the time I was like,
oh,
maybe if I get really good
that'll give me some free shoes,
you know,
because,
uh,
I mean for sure I knew that you could
get sponsored whenever that meant.
You know,
it was like,
oh,
they'll send you free ropes and they'll
give you free shoes and they'll give you
a harness.
Like,
that's so rad,
you know?
And so,
um,
so I picked up a little sponsors
like that where I was like,
oh,
now I'm getting my free shoes.
I'm so psyched,
you know?
Wow.
And then,
um,
and then it sort of has
like slowly snowballed,
you know,
are like,
oh,
now they're actually paid me.
Like my first,
my first,
uh,
my rope sponsor was the first people to
pay me and they were paying me 100 bucks
a month and I was like,
yeah,
I'm making 100 bucks a month.
Rope sponsor one of those ropes might've,
uh,
like nylon,
same as every other.
Does anybody make a hemp one?
Uh,
that's like the old school.
It's been replaced.
Is the nylon better?
Yeah,
the nylon is way better.
What is a z?
You can get tighter.
It can get stronger.
Is that what it is?
That's probably durability I think.
And I think part of its elasticity,
I think hemp like stretches more and,
and breaks easier and whatever.
Not on,
it's just better.
Yeah.
There's no like a dude,
just try to keep it real and go climbing
with hemp rope and everybody else like,
Hey,
what the fuck for sure.
With the ropes,
nobody's like,
I want to go old school.
I want to use the oldest route possible.
People we're with the hemp man.
No impact.
Like a weird sort of,
um,
attachment to it.
Like not for when your life depends on it.
And nobody's like,
I want him.
All right,
well maybe they do and
they're not here anymore.
It was exactly,
yeah.
They smoked a little too
much and they were like,
oops.
It turns out him doesn't really hold.
I got to,
I have these tea,
this tee shirt line,
higher primates and the biggest complaint
was that why are you selling hemp tee
shirts dude or under the
amended a pimp welcome hump.
That's never been a habit
teacher that didn't feel like
I was wearing a grain sack.
Oh,
what's that one guy that makes those
bags that you're friends with that sora
that sir,
I have it that Sarah a tee shirt.
Hemp tee shirt is soft as fuck.
Was a really,
really nice,
it's thick and meaning.
Well that's not why I like it.
The this is you like high end thin,
lightweight cotton.
It's cotton and uh,
it's like a blend cotton,
some,
some sort of nylon or something like that.
Nice body shirts.
Just what feels,
oh that
Midwest guys,
they're like,
oh,
you can see my nipples through
the shirt you don't like.
So you are you looking for
something to drape over your friend?
Hi,
my sexy.
Uh,
that's what it is.
I just like things that are lightweight.
They don't restrict me when I move,
but uh,
yeah,
that's where it has great shit.
He's,
he's,
he wants to sponsor the podcast,
so we'll just do a cut line.
That's where it makes some gym bags,
laptop bags,
but back all of its high quality hemp,
Colorado recently,
uh,
as,
as far as,
um,
the new thing that's been passed
that makes marijuana legal,
it also makes growing hemp legal.
And the first guy is stepping
up to start a hemp farm.
So awesome.
We have to start a Kickstarter
for his legal fund from the DEA
comes and locks them up and some,
because of the,
like the National Defense
Authorization Act and the Patriot Act,
that guy becomes a terrorist and
they lock him in some fucking sell in
Guantanamo Bay.
And that's not a joke,
folks.
Have you,
if you're selling drugs in any way,
shape or form,
you're like a terrorist now.
And if you're selling hemp,
even though it's not even psychoactive
and not the psychoactive form of
marijuana,
it's still federally illegal and
they would treat you the same way.
They would treat someone
who was growing heroin.
It's so stupid.
It's so fucking stupid because what what
people don't understand is we sell hemp
at on it.
We have hemp protein.
It's delicious.
It's nutritious.
It's you don't test positive for
THC because there's not any in it.
You get this stuff from the male plant,
the hemp plant,
the cannabis plant.
It doesn't have any
psychoactive capability.
You would have to get like a
whole forest of it to get high,
but,
but it is very nutritious
and it is very illegal.
We have to buy from Canada,
so we're allowed to have it,
but we can't grow it.
It's the dumbest thing in the world,
so they buy it.
We have to,
the Canadians have to grow it.
We get it from them and then we sell it,
but if we grow it,
they'll lock us in jail
for a hundred years.
If you grow the plants that you,
you need to make hemp protein powder
or hemp oil or any of that shit,
they'll just lock you in
jail for federal crimes.
It's insane.
It's unbelievable how
dumb the the world is.
It's just,
it's really,
it hurts my brain sometimes that it's
2013 and that with the it access to
information that we have the world and
the government still hasn't caught up.
The people in positions of power are
still operating like it's the 1950s in the
1960s and everybody's fucking stupid.
And it's,
it's really amazing.
It's drives me crazy.
How many people get high and climb most?
Whoa.
I'm not going to do it though,
but yeah,
I would think that,
um,
maybe not most,
but a lot say a lot.
I wouldn't do it.
Yeah.
There's a last place
you want to be paranoid
lunches.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Warm.
You have the Munchies,
you got five hours to go
to get to the top point.
You need a quail egg.
There's some specific
nests that you'd go to.
It's been mapped out.
Hikers Digest,
however 60 go up there and
eat that fucking port birds,
eggs.
Try to get enough energy to make it
to the top so you can stay alive.
Yeah.
You don't want to get the munchies
or climbing a mountain.
Do you have a poop bag and stuff when
you go up there or do you just check for
you if you're growing up for
like a week or some of them?
Yeah.
I mean if you're doing day missions,
how are we in the middle of a climb?
Yeah,
it happens.
You just let it go.
What do you think you do
it?
Just take a break to take
your pants off later.
I know for sure you take your pants off
and you do while you're climbing with
no,
there was a little ledges
and little stances,
like something you can share.
You get there and you just go
buck wild the rest of the way.
Just do whatever you go naked.
No,
no,
no.
You just shake the shit out,
put it back.
You don't poop your pants.
I mean,
you put it down,
you take a poop and then the best,
the best is to shit put where you poop
onto a rock and then you hurl the rock
off into the abyss.
Shit pudding.
It's like,
it's pretty legit.
Okay,
so you've never been climbing,
you just shit your pants.
No,
that's what I thought you meant when
you said your shit all over the place.
I need just let him know.
The worst case scenarios is
that you have a robot bonding.
You have to poop immediately.
And so you just like swing to the side.
You pull your harness and
pants as far as you can't eat,
just poop all over the wall.
That's like the worst case scenario.
You really,
wow.
We need to make videos of this video.
There's an amazing climbing video of
a dude actually pooping his pants.
Oh,
that you some friends on that up.
How do you find it?
Just Google a Boogie
till you poop because uh,
the,
the guy was climbing a route called
Boogie till you puke and then he went up
there and then he pooped himself
various but you took you poop.
Yeah.
You just gotta be careful about your
diet when you're climbing up fucking
mountains.
Do you,
do you watch your diet and
you have like a very specific,
um,
nutritious diet?
A little bit.
I actually,
I've been vegetarian for like
a month and a little bit.
Yeah.
How do you like him?
That I don't know.
It seems all right.
I mean,
we'll see.
I feel the exact same.
Is this the one with the video?
The Guy Shane?
Yeah,
totally.
It's actually,
it's one of my favorite car videos.
Yeah.
And is this,
um,
requires a rescue?
Let's see.
So you see free soloing this?
No.
So he has a rope and everything,
but the thing is he's
calming a wide crack and uh,
like it's too big for him to put
his hands in fists into or whatever.
So he has to wedge his leg in
and so he gets his leg stuck,
like stuck,
stuck.
Oh Wow.
So this is him being like,
Oh God,
I'm stuck.
And so then this other buddy who was
filming it is down there trying to help
them like extra cans,
like little shits on him.
Well,
no,
he's shitting his pants.
But
no.
Is this ever happened to
you where you get stuck?
Then he starts dry even
cause he's all over.
It's back.
Pretty Gross.
Wow.
Fucking mouth.
So this was during like the
Squamish mountain festival,
big climbing party up in,
up by Vancouver.
You know,
everybody parties as France.
I Shit my pants.
Does he get out of this?
And by the way,
this has two podcasts in a row.
Well we showed you shit.
Your pants videos.
Yes.
We showed that George Brett Shit,
your pants story trip.
This guy get out of this.
Eventually they
torture video.
This is scary.
He's stuck and shits his pants puke.
And the guy below him is like
just down when the relaxed,
one of my really good friends,
he's just try to help them out.
You know,
it's pretty butted.
Wow.
They're both are good friends.
Now when you do this climbing,
I'm ignorant to this as well.
When you,
when you climb up the mountain
and you're using ropes,
um,
how do you do it?
What do you start out?
Do you like knock something in as
soon as you climbed a certain part,
knock something in that secure and then
connect your rope to it and then keep,
keep unconnecting it.
Do you recap?
You said generally you
started the ground with um,
what's called a rack of gear,
like an assortment of gear that you
have little things that you can put into
cracks or like,
you know,
whatever,
put into cracks journey and uh,
and so you climb up and
you put them in as you go,
you clip your rope into him.
So at any time if you fall,
you just fall,
doubled it.
And to the last piece of gear,
you know,
because you climb like say five
feet above the last piece of gear.
So if you fall,
you fall that five feet plus the
five feet of slack that you had to.
So how does it relax or how does the,
how does the robe disconnect from the one,
the second person has to
climb up it after you.
So if you're climbing
like a thousand foot wall,
then the first person climbs,
you know,
say a hundred feet and stops.
And then brings up the
second person and then the,
then they do it again over
and over the whole way.
It's called pitches or like rope lengths.
So you climb like one rope length and
then you do the next one and then you do
the next one.
Is the technology for these pieces of
equipment so good that nothing ever fails?
I mean for the most part,
I mean like everything breaks,
you know,
like everything in life will
break in the right circumstances.
But um,
but climbing year is really well made,
well manufactured and
like pretty well tested.
So,
um,
I mean,
yeah,
there are circumstances where you can
like trust your life to like a piece of
gear and like one little widget that
you put into a crack and you're like,
well,
you know,
but generally you back things up,
you have it all tripled or whatever.
Like,
and these things that you put into cracks,
they separate or something like it.
Now they call it cams
there caming devices.
So the two lobes sort of like
an umbrella or something.
So you pull a trigger and
they can contract and then
you put it into the crack
and then they expand outward
and then when you pull on them,
they expand outward even further.
And so they went to
themselves into the crack.
Ah.
You know,
it's,
you know,
it's just a simple camming thing.
So it's just the pressure of that pushing
just much like that guy was climbing
them.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
It's counter pressure.
And how was it designed?
Like what does it made out of?
Like aluminum I think,
cause it's light.
Wow.
But I mean they're rated to,
I mean they,
they go through a whole rigorous
testing process and they're,
they're pretty solid
stuff to following things.
What really freaks me out when they fall.
Hang on that thing,
eh?
Yeah.
But you see that so often when,
as a climber,
you know,
that happens all the time.
And so it's just not,
you know,
it's totally normal.
So climbers are just used
to falling and getting,
so I'm sure like as a fighter,
you used to get knocked over.
You don't have any climbers used to
falling cause you're always to get better.
You have to push yourself to failure.
And so you're constantly falling,
you know,
obviously not for Solos but like,
but you know,
the majority of the time you have a
robe on and you're climbing to failure.
Now do you,
when I,
when I asked you about your diet,
do you try to stay light?
Does that make it easier?
One of the things when we did fear factor,
one of the stunts that we had was,
uh,
people,
they were hanging over
this bridge by their,
and they dropped into the water.
You know,
it wasn't that far,
but it was just the idea was
like who can hang on the longest?
And women won because they were lighter.
Yeah.
Because they were lighter because
we had one guy who was like a,
like a football player.
He was big,
strong guy.
Could not have that hands.
I mean,
yeah,
just small chest muscles.
Yeah.
Well being a big guy,
he's like a huge liability
if you're trying to hang on.
Yeah,
that's what I would imagine.
So do you,
um,
make sure that you don't
gain weight or do you mean,
I mean,
I love eating pastries and
stuff so I don't watch too much,
but,
um,
but I mean I try,
yeah,
for sure.
Very thin.
It must be a lot of calories.
Not that thin.
I mean,
Chris,
well you're not fat,
muscular.
I didn't mean that.
Certainly have muscle,
but I mean you're not a fat guy mean,
but you can't,
I mean you couldn't go climbing all
the time and it'd be a fat dude,
you know,
cause it does burn a lot of calories.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
well just being outside all
the time and exercising,
it's going to get you pretty fit.
Like when you have like
a big climb that day.
Do you,
do you prep yourself?
Do you have like a pre climb meal?
Are you pretty much the same?
All the time?
I'd just eat stuff.
Just whatever you want.
Yeah.
I see.
And so just try not to eat
too much or like go hog wild,
you know?
Right.
And no drinking.
Yeah.
But that's just,
cause I'm not into it.
I don't know.
I just don't like it.
That seems like the worst place
to ever be where that guy was,
where it was hung over and he
was in the middle of the client.
That's exact.
That's,
you know,
that's part of the reason I don't drink.
I look at stuff like that.
I'm just like,
what does aster,
yeah.
What is your mindset
while you're climbing?
What do you,
what are you thinking of when you're,
when you're doing it?
No one's around.
It's just you.
I mean,
it depends.
So like on hard stuff,
I'm probably not really
thinking about anything.
I'm just executing the
movements that I have to do.
You know,
what people say about being in the moment
or a flow and all that kind of stuff.
I don't know.
I'm just doing what I do on easy stuff.
It's the same as like going jogging or
swimming laps or anything where you just
think about whatever
you think about dinner.
I think about your to do
list and things like that.
Just so when they,
when it gets to the point where you
must focus exactly on what you're doing,
that's what you like it.
Yeah,
well,
I mean there's something fun about
just going out and going jogging too,
you know,
like just climbing up a
big peak or something.
And then when you get to the top
looking around and being like,
Oh that was fun.
But keeping her really
mellow the whole time.
But for sure the,
the harder stuff,
when it requires that
extra little something,
I mean that is more rewarding.
What does it feel like when you
get to the top of like hard stuff?
You just have crazy shit like I'm in
generally it gives kind of a general
satisfaction.
You know,
you're like,
that's red and Jay.
Well,
and also you're always in
these beautiful places.
The view's always amazing.
You know,
you're always by yourself
doing something really cool.
So I mean there's always that like,
you know,
Alation with like being where you are.
But then there's also that
deep satisfaction of like,
I just did something very
hard and did it well.
You know,
how many chicks started bombing on you
once you had this 60 minutes piece sued?
Not that,
not that many.
Get the fuck out of here.
That's ridiculous.
I don't believe that I
don't have that much game.
But you don't have,
you don't need any game.
I live in a band,
has a door that opens,
is it checked this willing to come inside.
Trust me.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll hang in the
wrong places or some shit.
He can't say you have no game dude.
That's ridiculous.
You're this climbing freak.
Okay.
That in itself is game maybe.
Yeah.
I didn't listen to it is,
you know,
it might not be your,
your main motivation,
but for,
you know,
most human beings,
one of the reasons why they get
really good at shit is to get pussy.
Well,
no,
for sure.
As I was getting better at climbing every,
you know,
every time I was like,
Oh,
if I got on the cover
of a climbing magazine,
then I'd get laid and then,
and then you get on the
cover and you're like,
dude,
nobody's calling.
It gives a shit,
you know?
And then you're like,
Oh,
if I get interviewed and like
men's journal or something,
then I'll start getting laid.
And then you're like,
dude,
turns out nobody reads that shit either.
You know.
I wouldn't feel like men's journal,
like all those fitness magazines,
you buy it and when you're at the airport
and you'd let go at that like that and
they leave in your fucking
cover of national geographic,
all that.
That'll get me laid like turns out no.
Well not a lot of people reading
the problem.
Yeah.
But that 60 minutes piece,
that had to be a big difference between
everything else he did and then the
subsequent viewings of it on the Internet.
Yeah,
for sure.
I found out about it.
I didn't see it live.
It was a,
I think Twitter thing.
Someone sent me a link and said,
you've got to check this out.
And I think I jumped out of my
chair and I climbed on top of it.
Like those cartoons where
there's a mouse on the ground,
you know,
are you in a crouch and you just,
my feet were on the chair and I
was watching new climate thing.
It was all,
what the fuck is he doing?
You need a sex scandal or something?
No,
you don't need to,
I need a bigger van through dollars
hemp fan mean what the heck?
There was some online thing,
it was like a fuzzy dice ESPN like
list of top athletes or some shit.
And I beat Coby Bryant because
I hadn't had a sex scandal,
you know,
because they had this
whole algorithm that like,
you know,
took it and all of these different
things that you've done versus,
but then divided by the number of terrible
scandals you've had and all that dude
up beat Kobee because I live clean,
you know,
it's kind of classic.
That's hilarious.
I forgot what that one also shows how
stupid that fucking thing is that the
algorithm is retarded.
But um,
but you know,
I thought it was pretty funny.
It is pretty funny now,
um,
have,
have there been traditionally a lot of
girls that do this solo on there too?
I think too,
in the world ever.
I don't know.
Yeah,
basically.
Basically no,
but there are a handful
of girls that do do that,
but are there girls that do
like a lot of the rope stuff?
Yeah.
I mean,
especially in Europe,
I mean it's probably 50,
50 split,
you know,
real in the u s maybe it's 60,
40 or 70.
30.
But it's that big.
Yeah.
It's pretty close to get audience buddy.
I mean if you go to a gym style for you,
then now this town,
as far as chicks,
you need to go.
Those are the ones who are going
to be the most impressed with you.
You're what?
They're all private gravel faces.
Their faces have holes all over it.
Gravel face.
Why
he doesn't have from hitting?
No,
it looks fine.
Yeah,
but they probably have it in there.
I'm not even gonna go there.
Probably fuck up more though.
Is that what you were going to say?
I mean,
honestly,
nowadays are the majority of
climbers climbing the gym in a city.
You know,
it's not like rugged mountain people.
It's just like college kids and
stuff to like go bolder in the gym.
And that's how you started.
You started in Sacramento.
Bad Ass town.
Love Sacramento.
Really liked doing standup up there.
They're wild.
It's like a,
it's like a combination of,
um,
like country people and city people.
It's like a weird sort of a blend,
you know?
Yeah.
It's kind of a Hickish city.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
Now,
these people that,
that do these rock climbing gyms
like that own them and stuff that,
do most of them do the
stuff that you like,
not the stuff that you do,
but the,
the mountain stuff,
or is there a two distinct camps?
There's people who just do Jim
rock climbing and you know,
I wouldn't say that
they're distinct camps,
but for sure there are people
who just climb in the gym,
especially like the Bay area around,
uh,
you know,
San Francisco and Berkeley and all that.
They're probably,
you know,
thousands of climbers that to them,
rock climbing just means going to the gym.
Hmm.
You know,
but then,
but then maybe half the people in the gym,
also God doors every weekend and all that.
You know,
it would seem to me that the,
the rock climbing that Jim could not be
nearly as exciting even if it was real
but,
but you know,
I mean whatever,
they're also people doing like zoom
button in the gym to work out or whatever
that meant.
You know what I mean?
Like chooses something and climbing
and certainly like more fun than,
than most ways to work out.
You know what I was going to get
to is when you first started,
you did it in the gym and what,
when,
what was the feeling when
you did your first mountain?
You mean like big outdoor climbing and
she was like going from doing it in the
gym to going to a mountain and you know,
in climate.
I mean honestly the first,
the first time climbing outside I liked
didn't like it as much cause it was
like,
oh how do you find the holds and all that,
you know,
like how do you do it?
Cause it's like different sports really.
I didn't know how to do it.
But then as I've learned
and as I got more into it,
you start to appreciate and you're
certainly in a more beautiful location,
you know?
That's kind of the main thing.
Does it give you a different sense of
accomplishment is what I was trying to get
at?
Yeah,
for sure.
It just feels different,
right?
Yeah.
I mean when you get to the top
of something in the gym yet,
you know there's some satisfaction
in the physical achievement.
You're like,
oh,
I'm stronger than I used to be.
Or I learned how to do some technique.
But like when you get to the
top of something outside,
you're like,
that was rad.
You know,
like this is a worthy objective,
whatever.
It's like inherently,
you know,
it has more inherent in eating.
One of the things I saw
on the 60 minutes thing,
so they asked you to hold up your fingers.
You have a,
you have really big like fat fingers.
Right.
That's know from just climbing
and clawing at things.
Yeah.
I think it was maybe from climbing
cracks where you put them in a wedge and
Torque on them and stuff.
Did you have to condition your hands
in any way or did it just happen?
This is 17 years of climbing,
you know?
Well that's what you need to tell girls.
Like girls need to know that if they
know about his hands and his strong
fingers.
Do you think that means
that he is a strong deck?
Is that what I'm saying?
That he's really highly powerful
as many years.
What's that?
I have a condition for this
helps you wedge in the cracks.
Yeah.
So you,
you have to like at some point in some
time where you're literally getting like
two inches of your fingers
in a crack or less.
I mean,
less evil.
What's the smallest amount that
you're actually holding your body?
An inch.
I mean the just like
half of your last pad.
So half of the day.
Yeah.
And that's,
you're holding your whole body up.
Well,
I mean,
you have your feet on things too.
You know,
probably really,
really small things.
But Jesus Christ,
I mean,
it can't be,
I mean that,
that would be like when it's really hard,
you know,
best case scenario,
you have your whole hand sunk in,
you know,
and it's like attached to
the mouse grip like cracks,
the most difficult thing to navigate no
cracks or actually like the most secure
thing to navigate really is a,
because once you put your fingers
in or your hand in you can,
uh,
so like if you put your hand into a crack,
you move your thumb down and gets fatter
and then it wedges and shape like a
sort of,
sort of like a camming device.
Like I was talking and you just make your
hand fatter and then it gets locked in
place.
And so once you have your
hand locked in like that,
I mean,
you could just,
you know,
I mean,
you just hang off.
I'm like,
yeah,
exactly.
You Shit your pants.
Totally fine.
But so like when I'm climbing a hand jams,
like it feels like I'm
walking or something,
you know,
I'm just like,
I can climb.
Well,
I have climbed thousands and thousands
of feet of hand jams like with no,
you know,
just whatever.
Nope.
You've been doing this for 17 years.
What keeps you doing this?
What is just rad?
Awesome.
I mean after,
as soon as we're done,
I'm driving to Vegas to go climbing
again and then I'm flying to Mexico in a
couple of days for like
a month road trip thing.
And when you're doing a lot of these,
you're doing them just by yourself.
You just pulling up,
showing up and climbing.
I wouldn't say,
I mean the big soul is the
stuff that you've seen.
I mean I maybe do like four
or five days like that a year.
Okay.
Those are so that you're doing with ropes?
Yeah,
I climb with a partner in
a rope 99% of the time.
And then you know,
the videos and stuff that you've seen
or like the playoffs and the super bowl
of,
of climbing,
you know,
but you're not seeing all the
practice and all the like,
you know,
the years that go into like
getting ready for the Superbowl.
Oh Wow.
So for you,
it's just a thrilling,
fun thing to do and it
hasn't lost any of its charm.
I mean,
the charm has transitioned.
I think as I get older,
like now I love the travel more and like,
you know,
I'm pretty excited about going to Mexico
and traveling around and like seeing
new places and all that,
you know.
Whereas when I was younger,
it was just a matter of like trying to
do physically do hard news and being
like,
oh,
I can do whatever this boulder
problem that I couldn't do before.
And you know,
it was like seeing that growth.
Now I'm kind of like,
ah,
you know,
there's always somebody who's going to
be stronger and better and whatever.
Like it doesn't really matter
how hard the moves are announced,
the cooler for me to go to like cool
places and climb new things and all that.
But you know what I mean?
I still love climbing.
No.
What is your life like now in terms of
like media obligations and how much,
how much of that stuff has changed?
Um,
I mean six since 60 minutes and it's
obviously kind of blown up quite a bit.
Um,
yeah,
I'm juggling a lot more
like speaking opportunities,
you know,
I mean stuff like this where I'm like,
oh cool,
I'll check out something new and
like see what it's all about.
Um,
but he did this cause for folks listening,
he had no idea what the podcast
was and never listened to it.
Just had been know just hounded
by people online that I was like,
wow,
I'm here.
It must be cool.
But then also like my
best friend lives in La,
so I was like,
oh,
it works out.
You know,
I'm just kind of put them together.
That's kind of how I tried to
do all my media slash you know,
whatever those kinds of obligations.
I try to lump it into what I'm already
doing or like make it fit right.
It seems to work.
All right.
Do you still live in that van?
Yeah,
I mean it's parked out front but wow.
But now I'm probably overseas like half
the year and so then I just leave the
van parked somewhere and you know,
camp or do whatever.
Um,
now like when you live in a van w do
you just like a shower at a gym or
something?
Like what do you do?
Or River or never?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
whatever.
Yeah,
you just make it work.
I mean,
oftentimes are like,
so I'm going to Vegas
and I'll be in the van,
but um,
I mean,
I'll be staying at one
of my friend's houses,
probably.
I would probably be sleeping in the band,
but I can use this house.
You can use the kitchen if I want,
whatever,
you know,
so everything you own every year,
your whole life is in a van mostly.
I mean,
my mom's house in Sacramento has like
some other random piles of stuff in it,
you know,
like camping gear that I knew
that I wouldn't need on this trip.
You know,
I just leave it at mom's house.
Wow.
Yeah.
Do you,
do you ever like,
say,
man,
I got to get a fucking apartment?
No,
definitely not.
Like,
why would you pay rent for a
place that you don't ever go to?
Well,
a lot of people they go
and they lie down in a bed.
Aye.
I'm just saying they're pussies with
their silly bed while you're camping on a
ledge.
I sleep really well on the van though.
Honestly it's so,
you know,
the end of my sleeping
bag and I'm just like out.
How do you know where to go?
Do you have like,
like when you come to a new town,
do you have to find a good parking spot?
Yeah,
I mean it takes a little dune.
You sorta get the hang of it.
I mean like a suburban streets
that don't seem to like,
I mean basically if you see
a van parked for a night,
someone that's totally normal.
You've got a friend and then a 24
hour grocery stores are always fine.
Like,
you know,
gas stations,
whatever,
rest areas.
Like do you ever get hassled?
Yeah,
I mean I've,
I've had a lot of cops like check in,
you know,
and like make sure the car is not stolen
or like wake up and see a cop behind
you,
like running your plates,
but then they just peace out
when they see it's not stolen.
Things like that.
You have ever COPCO dude,
I'm a big fan.
Can You oh actually it actually,
yeah.
Actually I have but uh,
only in like a little
climbing town in Utah.
Downtown.
Yeah.
Actually how everybody called my lab.
Do you know my lab?
It's like a huge mountain biking area,
but it's like the heart of the word,
but I don't know what could calls it
from the Old Testament if you've been
reading a lot of,
uh,
you know,
old tests.
No,
I mean I'm hurting.
Is it like an actual geographic location?
Yeah,
I was actually in
California for some reason.
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
way eastern Utah,
like right by the border with Colorado.
It's really cool.
It's the red sandstone desert where you
see like arches and like really pretty.
Like I was crazy things that are just
carved because of the wind in the road.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Oh,
that is so bizarre.
It's really pretty landscape.
You must see like some of the coolest
spots in the world when it comes to,
you know,
all these climbs here.
For sure.
That's like,
that's what I'm saying that like that
is becoming more of the appeal for me.
You know,
just to go to these amazing
places and climb like cool things.
Yeah.
For folks who've never seen nothing
on what we were talking about,
the sound somehow or another,
the rock eroded to look.
It looks like it was constructed
like a freestanding art.
Yeah.
Crazy arch may not have stone.
It just shows you that although the
randomness of nature with the weird things
that can occur,
I went on a northface expedition to Chad
in the dead center of Africa to climb
unclimbed sandstone and towers and arches
like exactly what we're talking about
in Utah except it was and Chad,
why we drove across blank empty desert,
like just completely
flat sand with no road,
just driving gps for three days across
like flat nothingness until we got to
these crazy towers.
Oh my God,
you guys are driving for three days
through the desert is out of control.
She drove,
we drove for two days,
just flat and knocked me.
And so you don't see
anything in any direction,
so much gas to drive that long.
I don't know.
We had this outfit or just,
you know,
that's what he does.
I think he knew how to do it,
you know,
but the day's drive well but driving it
like 27 miles an hour through the sand.
Yeah,
because you're driving across like it'd
be like going to the Mojave desert and
it's driving cross country completely
straight for three days anyway.
But so after two days we randomly passed
these two dudes on camels that were
doing the same thing.
They were just questioning across
the desert on their camels.
Randomly,
randomly rated on the,
I'm sure they were like
going to trade or something.
Yeah,
we just was,
is there a path you are on?
That's the thing is we were just,
we were following gps
coordinates across it.
The Virgin desert,
you know,
it was like,
it was kind of out of control.
We were like,
what the fuck are these
guys doing out here?
Why?
You know,
and like,
yeah,
who were the guys?
They're just like desert nomad dudes.
You know,
just like indigenous folks.
I mean they were just normal
dudes on their normal life,
but you're just like,
it's hard to believe that
that's their normal life.
Just like taking a camel for five days
across the blank desert with no food or
water.
It's hard to wrap your head around the
fact that that's how people lived for a
long,
that's how people still live.
That's what's so crazy
about going to chat.
It's like we were meeting,
you know,
people that live there that like in their
entire life will probably never touch
pavement or like asphalt,
you know,
they just live in sand and that's it.
But for all of existence,
they just,
gender goats 10 there,
they're a little donkeys and
stuff and you're just like,
oh my God,
it's pretty hardcore and that,
and that's why I like the
travel experiences are
becoming more important to me
than the actual climate sort of.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
But that's a really paradigm shifting.
Yeah,
it's pretty heavy stuff.
You know,
you're like,
whoa,
holy deed man.
Three days driving on virgin desert,
nothing to the left,
nothing to the right.
Nothing in front of you in the morning.
So we would drive until we got tired,
we'd park,
we'd do dinner,
we'd go to bed.
And then in the morning when
you got to go take a poop,
I mean there's no cover in any
direction because it's just flat.
So you'd basically just walk in any
direction until everyone else got really
small and then you would just take
a poo and then you just walked back.
Because there was no,
you know,
it's not like,
oh I'm going to go behind that tree.
Is that you just have to walk though.
People are small.
You take photos of this.
Yeah,
I mean it's all,
yeah,
it's all professional.
I didn't take quite as much,
but it must've been no your poop.
Then I have photos of Brian Cowen pooping
when we a camping in Montana with a
little flag in it.
We were going to put it on Twitter.
That a,
if you could find it,
we'll give you 1000 bucks.
It's on the Missouri River and we were
going to give like rough coordinates.
Take a picture of yourself by,
we'll give you 1000 bucks,
but you can't just sleep poop tear.
You have to like put it in bio bag,
back down,
pack it out and human
poop is really gross.
Like if you run across like cows,
poop is a lot of cows out there.
Cow Poop.
It's kind of gross to,
it's kind of gross,
but it doesn't smell that bad difference
in human shit and cow shit is pretty
shocking.
No,
no cow shit also smells horrible until
it's been sitting there for like a year
and it's all baked by the sun.
That too,
like what you're talking about is like
fried cow pies that are all dead and like
sterilized,
you know?
Yeah.
But I've been around,
but the actual cow taking a shit
and they can't fuck with a human.
I Dunno.
But it depends.
It depends on the,
depends on burgers.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Just shitting out cheeseburgers and
whiskey that he just goes to show you guys
do to work on your diet a little bit.
That's not made.
I'm saying some other dude,
it was some random dude just shit.
And we're grading it.
That's what you're talking about.
But uh,
yeah,
you can't just leave your shit
out there in the Missouri,
but you can't in the desert.
Did you encounter any animals
while you were doing this?
Dry?
We saw tons of little things like
little desert foxes and stuff and um,
yeah,
like,
cause they'll type,
uh,
I don't know,
you know,
different antelopes and what are they,
uh,
eating out?
They're like tiny little shrubs.
I mean,
there were like,
you know,
there'd be a Bush every 600 yards,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I mean there is some vegetation but it's
just like flat sand with like a shrub
and then like a mile later you're like,
there's a little tiny tree,
you know?
And then whatever,
no snakes,
nothing like that.
That and not really know what
a strange ecosystem that is.
When we got to where we were going,
there were these amazing
stand stone towers and then
there was like more whether
there was more going on I think
because of this Phil cliffs and stuff.
So maybe it traps more
moisture or whatever.
So,
and there were more people living there
because there was more vegetation.
Um,
you know what,
I'm still pretty much desert.
Yeah.
I mean it's still full fledged desert,
but there were at least like shrubs,
kind of like the American
desert where you see,
you know,
like the Mojave and how
they get their water,
their wells every once in a while.
I mean,
I,
I assume,
I mean,
there was water running underground,
I guess,
because you could see like bands of
vegetation that we're supposedly like
washes,
you know,
like an underground river.
So one of the real mind fucks about the,
uh,
the topography of this
world is how it's variable.
Yeah.
How are you different,
different parts of the world.
They're not just variable but variable
in the same location over time to Egypt
where the Nile Valley
was like 9,000 years ago.
That was a rain forest.
But yeah,
that's,
that's the exact same type of
area that I'm talking about.
So,
um,
and it actually,
so no,
while we were there,
it was rad.
We went into a cave and
the cave paintings and,
um,
and I mean,
it's all just,
you know,
we're in the middle of nowhere.
And so you could see the
stick figure drawings and,
uh,
and it showed like
these big herder people,
you know,
like drawings of dudes like tending their,
their big,
uh,
cows and then them being
displaced by the camel people,
like the people of the
desert and all that.
And,
um,
and our outfitter was telling us that
was kind of showing the history of the
whole area because like as the,
as the desert advanced and like
the grasslands and forests,
you know,
receded like,
so Chad now all the,
all the big cow people now live in like
southern southern Chad where they're
still like vegetation and the rest
of the country is just desert,
you know,
as the Sahara or whatever this
the hell has like moved south and
desertification,
all that kind of stuff.
It's a really strange thing
that happens to the climate.
Yeah.
I mean it's pretty,
it's pretty interesting though to see
like cave paintings of like this whole
process of,
you know,
like different populations being,
replaced.
How many Ken's paintings do they know?
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
I think that the climate events are over
the last 10,000 years or whatever or
maybe even older.
Wow,
okay.
It was pretty,
I mean it was neat stuff for us.
We were like,
whoa.
Yeah,
it's really the key cave
paintings really freaked me out.
Have you ever seen that?
A Herzog documentary on a,
what's it called?
The cave of dreams or something like that.
Hold on,
let me find that for the folks who
are listening because it's a really
interesting,
they found some really old cave
paintings that predated what the,
like the most,
the,
the oldest before that by like
a pretty substantial amount.
Find a real quick
uh,
yeah.
Cave of forgotten dreams.
That's what it's called.
It's amazing.
It's in France.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's the oldest recorded cave paintings,
human or neanderthal.
Uh,
it's human.
I don't believe there's
neanderthal cave paintings.
I think we know that they made tools
and if you heard of this crazy bitch,
this,
there's a guy who wants to bring back.
Oh,
I just had just awesome.
I was thinking about that.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
I was like,
that seems like an opening.
A bag of worms versus your yeah,
right.
They're going to,
they're asking for,
it's some Harvard Guy,
right?
The inner tall baby.
It's a,
some guys asking a woman to,
um,
to carry or carry a
fucking neanderthal baby.
Um,
I have no idea why anyone has
letting this guy say this.
Well because nothing wrong with saying it.
Your problem with doing it,
it sounds fucking crazy.
But this guys,
his name is George Church
and he's from Harvard.
This is legit.
This is not like some,
you know.
Yeah.
Well the,
the,
the really scary thing
is that we don't need,
we don't know shit about neanderthals.
We have no,
they're,
they're built more like gorillas in the
RP people and their brains when they
built more like realism.
There are people,
five foot tall,
200 pounds,
really sick bones,
big head's,
bigger heads in human beings,
much larger brain zoo.
It's a really trippy thing.
The idea that this crazy fuck wants to
bring these things back and that the fact
that you could do it
inside of a woman's body,
it's pretty ridiculous.
Crazy asshole.
But,
um,
so no,
I don't believe that this a Werner Herzog
thing was that I'm pretty sure that it
was a,
um,
it's all,
uh,
it's all homosapiens at
the first one's a female.
The first baby.
Yeah.
Better.
Because if it's a man,
it's just going to start raping.
Just kind of go on a rape,
rape and cannibal rampage
when it gets to full grown,
you know,
who knows.
We don't know the behavior of a
neanderthals because it's been a lot of
speculation that neanderthals
preyed on the units.
They might take bids to the next level.
Well if I was praying on humans obviously
didn't pray enough cause they got
wiped out,
but he might have been wine.
We wiped him out.
You know,
we were just a little bit smarter.
There's,
there's a lot of speculation
as to what happened to them.
Um,
there's also debate as to whether or not
they interpret it with us or whether or
not we have a common ancestor.
Like where we are genetic material where
we definitely have a common ancestor.
No,
yeah,
we definitely have a common ancestor but
common enough that we have in the inner
tall genes in us,
you know,
cause they don't know
if it's from breeding.
This is like,
it's like kind of a iffy area.
They're trying to piece together now
whether or not it's from humans breeding
with it,
but interesting enough the pop,
the possibility of humans breeding with
it was only neanderthal males and human
females.
Why?
I don't know.
I think it's a scientific reason for the,
the the hybrid to be able to,
it's kind of weird because
it seems like you'd want it,
the neanderthal women to be able
to carry like the bigger baby.
Yeah.
I think because like I say,
being a woman and got torn apart by,
I think they're just saying it was rape.
I think that's what I was saying.
I think that was saying it was a,
you know,
a conquer thing.
Cause there's also speculation as
to whether or not neanderthals eight
homosapiens.
Hmm.
That's the weirdest thing that I would
have been aware of recently that I didn't
know about was how often native Americans,
other,
yeah.
Eight each other in Papa New Guinea
or stone under that kind of thing.
Are they really,
they're still in the cannibalism sort of,
they're all sending to a
lot of other freaky shit.
Like they're into having the
young boys in just their semen.
The semen tribes have,
a lot of people in the
states are starting to that.
They're called that Catholic priests.
This is a very different though.
This is like ritualized and open.
Whereas the Catholic priests thing is,
is uh,
in the,
in the confessional booth.
Yeah.
It's a little more scratch yours,
a little more sketch.
So these,
um,
these paintings in the
Werner Herzog documentary,
amazing stuff and their cave bears,
lions,
horses,
Bison,
Mamis Rhinoceros is,
and there are other animals between
30 and 32,000 year old drawings.
It's really amazing,
man.
Just think we managed to wipe out all
these different animals in the last 30,000
years.
Well,
they don't believe that people had a,
a play and wiping out the woolly mammoth.
There's,
there's,
there's thoughts about it.
But one of the more interesting thoughts
about the mammoth because the mammoth
extinction coincides with what they are
pretty sure now was significant meteor.
Meteor impacts meteor showers
somewhere around 12 13,000 years ago.
When they do the strata,
when they take soil samples,
they've found this thing called a,
it's like a,
a volcanic glass and impact glass.
It's big fit.
It's like it's green looking glass that
has come from either nuclear tests or
meteor impacts.
So when they find it all over the world
like 12,000 years ago and that sort of
coincides with some mass extinctions.
A lot of the scientists are starting to
speculate that that might've been what
wiped out a lot of things,
including a lot of like
major civilizations that the
world just got bombarded by
meteors at one point in time,
but somewhere around 12,000 years ago.
Hmm.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
pretty crazy stuff.
They think that might've had a part in
the saber tooth tiger and a wooly mammoth
and that uh,
some animals just weren't,
be able to make.
That was another animal
that trying to bring back.
They're trying to bring
back a wooly mammoth.
The Russian scientists trying to do that.
They need bigger carpets.
What,
what the fuck is with people
wanting to bring things back?
Like you know enough already.
How about some of them make an alien,
you know,
why is everybody bringing old shit back?
You know,
they probably are doing that.
They're just not telling us.
Maybe now you're out there camp and you
ever see something freaky ever hear a
big foot,
ever see a Ufo?
No,
nothing.
I don't really do the weird stuff.
You don't really do the weird stuff
like not into all the like weird,
random stuff like that.
I'm a very practical kind of guy.
You very practical.
Crazy mountain climber dude.
Yeah.
Very rational.
Rational.
Well,
you know by,
um,
by Ufos being irrational and the same
just because you haven't seen something
that's irrational,
would you,
would you freak out if you're out there
camping and all of sudden if an alien
landed Ufo flew overhead,
probably wouldn't freak out.
No,
but I'd be like that.
It's bad ass.
Do you think you'd still keep climbing
or would you like changed the subject and
start trying to,
trying to take time out to
chat with the alien or not?
I mean,
that's a good question actually.
I mean for sure if I had some kind of
crazy experience like that where I was
like,
I am 100% certain in their life,
in other planets,
like I probably would change my field a
bit because all of a sudden I'd be like,
there's definitely something like
more important going on in the world.
The real problem with,
um,
the,
of course with the idea that there's
some life from another planet that's
visiting us,
it's like where the fuck's the evidence.
That's the real,
that's what I'm saying about rational.
That's however,
if they're much more sophisticated than
us to the point where they can travel
from other planets,
it seems like they could be undetectable.
That's the same kind of arguments for,
you know,
whether there's a god or not,
it's like whatever.
Not really because the,
the actual fact of human life and
the fact that we have technological
superiority over all the animals.
When you look at all the other planets
and you extrapolate the amount of time
that they could have existed,
it's highly possible.
Yeah.
No,
I think it's highly likely
that there is in the universe.
I mean actually I think,
I'm sure there's,
I don't think any of us in the universe,
yeah,
just don't think they're
like messing around here.
But I see that and I agree
with you to a certain extent,
but then I see the fact that there's
so many fucking planets and we are
constantly trying to
explore these planets.
We're sending things to Mars,
we're,
we're looking with satellites and when
with telescopes and trying to observe
over time really,
really far apart.
Right.
My point is if we're constantly exploring
the universe as far as we can with our
limited technological capability in
2013 maybe that's just an aspect of
intelligent life period.
That intelligent life constantly
explores its dimensions.
Like maybe other really intelligent
life explore spiritually area.
They go inward.
They just,
you know,
that's good point.
Or both.
You know?
I just feel like part of
intelligence is being curious.
Part of being curious is
wondering if you're alone.
Part of being curious and wondering
if you're alone is looking.
So if I was a smart,
curious,
intelligent thing from another planet,
I think I'd go check out the space.
The university.
Hopefully when the aliens come,
they'll meet you there.
They're going to come to you,
dude,
you're going to be out there
camping and they got to go.
How come you're not shitting your pants
while you're climbing up that thing?
What are you doing up here?
Sleeping on a ledge.
50,000 feet above the earth.
50,000 that's a big mountain.
What is the biggest one
you've ever climbed?
What is the,
the biggest face?
Biggest faces is like 300 feet.
Probate.
Zach appetite.
And then you send money in Yosemite?
Yeah,
I think so.
And what's the legality for that stuff?
Did they totally fine?
Nobody hassles you about
climbing these things?
National Park.
I mean it's just,
you know,
recreation,
youth group,
whatever.
You just go fine.
Does there ever been any talk of
regulating it or keeping people from solo
climbing or anything like that?
No.
No?
I mean,
how would you regulate?
you know,
then you might as well be
regulating like fat people hiking,
you know,
because they're more likely to
have a heart attack or whatever.
Well,
that's the good point though.
The good point is personal freedom.
They definitely should be someone
to talk them into it though.
I don't think we should
put a gun to their head.
Um,
the personal freedom aspect of it,
I mean,
I'm a big believer and a big supporter
of personal freedom and this is,
I mean,
it's one of the few that a very few
people are exercising but is a really
radically dangerous pursuit
for the average person.
For you.
Maybe not,
you know,
you shake your head because a,
you're competent.
B,
you're aware and see it's something you
love to do and you've been doing your
whole life.
You have a massive amount
of experience for him.
But for the average
person and try to do it,
it could be mean if everybody
had to free solo clamp,
just stop and think about it via that.
It'd be a fucking raining people.
But if everybody put like 17 years
at work and the learning how,
and then,
I mean,
you know,
I'd probably be like,
there'll be no TVs,
there would be no cell phones,
there'll be no cars.
If everybody did that,
no one would get anything done because
they'd be just consistently focusing on
not falling in climbing.
Um,
but it's an interesting
personal freedom issue.
It's like,
well there are certain things that were
restricted from doing in this country
and this world and we're restricted
from taking a amount of chances.
But that one is just still completely
out there in the wild though.
It's one that I think like going hiking
or any kind of outdoor recreation is
pretty,
pretty unrestricted in the U s I'm here
alleged just wander into the woods and
go have an adventure.
I know,
but I mean the nanny state
government that we have,
I'm surprised that someone doesn't like,
hey,
you can't climb.
Um,
no,
get down from their son.
You know,
cause that's sort of the attitude.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean,
yeah.
No one ever gets in trouble
at all for climbing anything.
As long as it's not a public
building or something like that.
You don't think so unless
it's on private property,
in which case the
landowner gets to choose,
you know.
Oh,
wow.
So all public property,
like public lands and national parks,
do you have some kind of like
recreational management plan?
So I mean,
you're not allowed to like drill bolts
or like change the rock in different ways
because when you climb you often
and like put bolts for protection,
you know,
black bolts in there.
Yeah.
For if you're climbing up a blank face,
like say your brick wall hook a giant.
I Hook.
I mean it's small.
Yeah.
But it's small enough that
you can clip your care,
meaner into and then clip
your rope into the beaner.
But um,
so I mean,
most national parks
have some kind of plan,
you know,
limiting,
uh,
you know,
bolting and things like that are,
they have some kind of
like management use thing,
but for the most part you can
just go climb whatever you want.
Do you have any other crazy hobbies?
Uh,
no.
This is it.
This is just,
this fulfills all of
your time because travel,
I mean,
I read and I travel and I do stuff.
Yeah,
it's a fascinating life,
man.
I mean,
I know it's yours and you're like,
yeah,
yeah.
That's pretty normal.
You know,
it's not pretty normal.
It's pretty normal to you.
Well,
yeah,
but I'm,
but I mattered the most to me.
You know what I mean?
I would imagine to me it's super normal.
I'm like,
I think it's cool.
Well,
it is very cool.
It's very cool.
It's very interesting.
I mean your,
your approach to this whole
thing is a very unique,
you're a very unique
person and that's why,
um,
you,
uh,
are fascinating to
people and I think it's,
it's a very charming that you have
this math that you've said that like 10
times,
the more I talked to you
about how unique you are,
a compliment you like,
hey,
that's your take on things.
But that is also why
you're so good and you,
you,
um,
that's why it's so compatible,
you know,
with you,
your personality,
like how you,
how you roll with things.
That's it probably.
Okay.
Must Somehow or another contribute to
your ability to be so good at this or your
passion and desire the
way it fits in your,
your,
your square hole for your square peg.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean I think I just,
I've always loved it and um,
and I,
I mean I'd put a lot of work into it and
I figure anybody that like loves what
they do and work hard at it,
it's probably going to
get pretty good at it.
Do you have any goals?
Are there certain mountains
that you have not?
Yeah,
for sure.
I got all kinds of,
I have a lot of like travel goals,
like places I want to go climbing
and then I have actual like climbing
achievement goals,
you know,
things that I want to climb or
new things to do or whatever.
What's,
what's a big one?
It's one,
I don't know.
They're all there on the DL,
you know.
Oh you can't tell people what I mean.
Okay.
You don't want to talk about it?
No.
Well,
so I don't really set like specific so
long goals because I don't really like
the price.
Cause normally when you set a goal,
you go through the whole process
of like you set the goal,
you train for it,
you achieve it,
whatever,
you know,
you make it happen.
But the thing was so long because
I don't really like that pressure.
I don't want to feel
like I have to go solo.
Something.
So generally has that climate goals,
like retirement to climb
with a rope or you know,
places I want to go.
But for so long it's more
like a soloing fantasy,
you know,
like something I'd love to do and I'll
sort of keep it in the back of my mind.
Like what kind of shape
I'd have to be in to do it.
Or like,
you know,
what time of year I'd have to be in,
what kind of shape,
but um,
but it's never like that's
my goal for this season.
It's more like if it happens,
it'd be sweet.
If not,
you know,
whatever.
Why has no one come up with a
television show that follows you?
Climbing up mountains and,
and,
and broadcast.
I mean,
people have talked about it,
but the thing is after that,
after anybody chats to me for a while,
they're like,
turns out that guy's
actually really boring.
You're boring at all men.
Yeah.
I don't think you're boring it all.
Thank you.
Fascinating.
No,
you're mellow.
You're confused when Ella was born.
You,
I'm very interesting.
There's nothing,
there's nothing boring about you.
You have a very distinct personality,
a very distinct way of looking at
this very odd life that you have.
It's very compatible for what you do.
It's not boring.
Um,
what you do is not even
remotely fucking boring.
It's hair raising.
It makes people shit their pants,
my hands,
sweat.
Watching your fitness,
what I was talking about,
you know,
super bowl versus training.
You know what I mean?
Like you're saying the
Superbowl stuff looks amazing.
You know,
like the big solos,
you're like,
that's red.
But what she did on 60 minutes,
you said wasn't even that big.
Well,
no,
I mean,
but still I only do that kind of
thing handful of times a year.
You know,
the majority of the year I'm just going
out climbing with my friends and just
normal climbing.
You know the same thing that
people are doing in the gym except
they have shows,
okay,
we're going to have
like I don't give a shout back on
shops and they come in and they go,
hey man,
how much,
well give me for this band.
No.
And the guy's like,
I'll give you a two on it,
man.
I need to 50 I can't go to 50 I'll give
you a two 25 that's the fucking show
they're selling.
Dammit.
That kind of shit makes the world worse
and I don't want to contribute to that.
You would not be contributing it to him,
my friend.
What I'm saying is that there's,
people are fascinated by shit that's not
even close to is interesting as you are
what you're doing.
I really think it would
be an amazing show.
I think you're dead wrong.
I don't think there's,
there's been talk
like I doubt it.
I doubt there would be a show,
but I think there probably will.
Why wouldn't it be a show?
So when he's a fucking step is honestly,
there's not much content,
you know,
like because,
well what if you do like 10 episodes
or something and you have to sell us
something big for each one.
Like I don't want to not watch real
housewives of Beverly Hills and I'm glad I
have it.
This is the idea.
This is my idea.
You ready for this?
We may get a desk squad production.
Then what we're gonna do is we're going
to bring you with Brian in between all
of your climbing,
you're going to hang out with Brian and
all of his porn star friends and our
friends.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He thinks porn stars.
Oh yeah.
Kids at mass.
Oh,
I can hear you all the
best way they would like.
Yeah.
They would climb up and down them,
throw some shit on a ride.
Look peaked his interest.
He's like,
Whoa,
go kind of girls to be porn stars.
Do you want to meet them?
Well,
let's say it,
it came to Vegas last week.
We can make this happen.
That's an easy thing to make happen.
I'm not kidding.
Huh?
That's a really easy thing to make happen.
Yeah.
You want to go hang out with him?
How long had towns for
from this parking lot.
I was going to drive to Vegas,
but maybe you drive to hang
out with Brian in Burbank.
You know,
we'll go to off guard
with a bunch of skanks.
Bring seven of them.
And by skanks I say that lovingly.
Just cause he was the
funny thing to say ladies,
don't be hating.
Do what you gotta do a yeah,
he can introduce you that see that world
to you is like your eyebrows went up in
the air.
It changed the entire tone.
See that's how the show gets exciting.
We bring you with him in between
a solo climbs with porn stars.
Exactly.
We would spice it up.
Listen,
you're,
you're a mellow guy.
This would be a new,
unique curated experience.
Push my boundaries.
And so surely it's like going to Chile
or taking a fucking car and driving
across the desert for three days.
Basically we're going to chat
anywhere wherever you went.
You know what I'm saying is it's unique
in the cross and about four hours.
Could you really ain't
Chili's like this narrow.
Oh,
is it really?
I didn't know.
Damn geographically limited.
Have you,
have you ever climbed in Japan?
I have not,
but my family lived there
for a while actually.
I really,
yeah.
But your family lived in Japan?
I was conceived in Japan.
They were not in inches,
but I wish they were so much.
What did,
what did your parents do?
They were at the time they were teaching
English and then they both were like
college professors in
our teaching language.
Oh Wow.
My mom's a French teacher.
Wow.
So how many different countries
have you been to climate?
I don't know,
like 20.
30.
Um,
I dunno dude.
You live a fascinating life.
I think it's a,
it's,
you're a,
you're a really unique guy and I love
the fact that you don't think you are,
it's uh,
you know,
I understand.
That's why Brian hangs
out with these porn stars.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's a perfect example.
I can take you to the UFC next weekend.
Next weekend.
I'm finding Mexico on Thursday.
Oh Dude.
Cancel that shit.
Listen,
I'll will,
you want to see a crazy experience?
I'll take it to the UFC.
I'll get you front row seats for one
of the best UFC has ever do this.
Be happening this weekend.
This Saturday night at Mandalay bay.
Frankie Edgar's fighting Joe say Aldo,
JSA,
all those,
this guy from Brazil,
he's one of the top pound for
pound fighters on the planet.
So it's Frankie Edgar.
Frankie Edgar was a lightweight champion.
He's dropping down to one 45 to
fight this kind of super fight.
It's going to be fucking craziness.
People are flying in from Brazil.
They're flying in from the east coast.
It's guys from New Jersey.
It's two amazing fighters
and that's just one fight.
Alistair Overeem,
who's one of the biggest guys
in the heavyweight division,
265 pounds,
looks like a fucking superhero
from a comic book.
And he's fighting this guy,
Antonio bigfoot Silva was to cut weight
to make $265 that both giants and,
and Allister is a former
k one grand Prix champion,
like kickboxing,
k one at Grand Prix is like the
craziest kickboxing event in the world.
So he's this destroyer,
this guy who just does stand up straight
over who can kick through a wall.
He's a monster.
He didn't look,
pull up a picture of Alistair
Overeem because if you haven't seen,
just seeing this guy alone
is such a freak specimen of,
of humanity.
Six foot five,
265 pounds and literally
it doesn't even look real.
And Antonio Big Foot Silva
is like a literal giant.
He actually is a giant and big as me.
Well,
he's,
look at that.
That's over.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
And there's jet in the background.
That's me.
That's my gig.
I'm the commentator for the ultimate
fighting to make more crazy during this.
Yeah,
I do.
Um,
when I don't do this
or do stand up comedy,
I'm a commentator for cage fighting.
Yeah.
So you're back there and be like,
this guy's fucking yoked.
He's smashed that guy's head.
I'm announcing his official way in.
I'm in that,
I'm introducing him,
former k one grand Prix champions
in Strikeforce heavyweight champion.
Well,
I don't say that I w
I call out the weight.
See every fighter has no,
no I do.
I,
I was like,
how hard is that?
You fucking loser.
65.
That's one day.
And then the next day I'm the commentator
when I do is I explain the nuances of,
you know,
what's in my uterus and I got a death.
No.
Like what he has to look out for,
what,
what's going to happen
if he doesn't do that,
what's going to happen?
You know,
that's me at the wins.
It's a handmade video.
People get silly cause they took that
one picture and they photoshopped it,
you know about Photoshop right
out there in the woods.
Yeah.
Um,
but so,
you know,
it's,
if you can make it,
it would be a trip.
It will freak you out to be,
you know,
15 16,000 people completely sold
out Mandalay Bay events center.
It's going to be nuts.
It's kind of bad ass.
It's a wild thing to see live.
It is.
Why?
Cause you're gonna see the best martial
artists on the face of the planet.
Without a doubt.
I mean there's a few other guys that won't
be competing this Saturday night that
are also the best,
but the examples of of excellence that
you're going to get there between Overeem
and Aldo and Edgar,
just those guys in big foot Silva and
there's a guy named Damien Maia from
Brazil was the baddest fucking Jujitsu
guy on the planet and MMA and he's
fighting this guy,
John Fitch was this bad ass
American wrestler and Oh,
it's gotta be from your site.
Oh my God.
Are you compensating for it?
Yeah.
That's my,
that's my other job.
My job.
I keep a bunch of jobs.
I'm like a Jamaican.
I try to keep your hustle,
our jobs,
but these are all things
that I'm drawn to.
Much like your,
your thing with the mountain climbing.
It probably seems unreal
t that's what I'm saying.
Like it would be another paradigm shifting
moment that the UFC did to see how
fucking crazy it can be.
If you can stay please did actually get
in cause I mean cause I can just do that
in front row and we'll get
you front row experience.
I want to make sure that you are,
I will have you sit behind me.
I will give you a seat
right behind me for the UFC.
You will be right there.
The cage.
You could step forward and touch it
with your hand if you want him to.
Shit.
Yeah it'd be the nuttiest fucking
thing I've ever seen in your life.
I don't like.
Yeah,
they're going to get there.
People listen,
this is,
this is this their job,
their job is to try to hurt the other
guy and the other guy tries to hurt them.
But it's very scientific.
It's very technical,
very good experience.
So it's a great experiment.
What it is is is human
competition and it's,
you know,
one on one competition and
it's most difficult for him.
You're,
you're using your body to try to submit
and stop another person who's also using
their body and that's all you have.
You have pads over your knuckles and
your wits and your techniques and your
conditioning and your training and gut
and your ability to overcome the pressure
of the moment and all those things.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
Dude.
I remember my arm.
I just,
you should go.
I'm just going to Mexico to go climb.
You Go.
We'll fly in and Brian and he'll fly in.
A couple of gals with loose morals and a,
you'll have yourself a party.
Do you have anything
going on this weekend,
Bri?
You want to go?
Sure.
We just made a party and just
brought in Brian and you'll sit.
How about you sit next to him at the,
you have saved a bunch of ports or help
give you booze and they'll tell you
where to get the good ecstasy.
We might,
we might ruin your climbing career,
but trust me,
you're going to have a memorable weekend.
If you can get me a sec scan,
I'll be super site.
He can definitely get you a sex scandal.
I have to do is fuck
him and we'll find out.
That would be a [inaudible]
camera's in here.
We could just do right here.
We can do it right here.
Just clear off these salt
lamps and put the deer antlers.
Climb the lox store.
Yeah,
we could go up to,
yeah,
you could climb the parents.
Really low angle.
That's seems kind of fruity.
Pretty easy.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Did on fear factor where
they claimed the Luxor was,
they actually slid down?
It
probably was.
There was quite a few things they did
on fear factor that we're dangerous.
Did you have a call in
deciding what they did?
No,
I did not.
There was,
there was two times where
I would have said no.
One time where they had a ride bowls.
I definitely was not into this.
It was because they thought
they could actually get killed.
Yes,
they could have.
We had two different stunt coordinators.
There's this one guy from
the beginning who was like,
you know they're Badass dudes.
You know how you're
looking at like climbing,
not fine,
so his sky bet stop man.
His whole lives name's Perry.
Great Guy.
And his attitude was like,
yeah,
I would do it.
I'll fucking do it.
You know?
I was like,
if his idea was that
they want to be on TV,
they should do it too.
But I'm cool with a lot of
that until it gets to animals.
Animals are very unpredictable and this
thing was they were going to ride these,
I mean these bulls were fucking enormous.
I don't know if you've ever been like
right next to a riding bull before,
but I was standing on the like sort of,
there's like a platform next to where the
cages and I'm looking down at the ball
and I'm like,
no fucking way.
There's no way I would get on that thing.
There are thousands of pounds and they're
just fucking in there and you see as
muscles and I go onto
that to ride the ball.
They don't get to ride the bull very
long because the bull fucking sends him
into orbit within like three seconds.
Good Rodeo guy tries to
get to eight seconds.
It's not like,
you know there's a guy who
could just do it all day long.
Like you can climb all day
long and no one can do that.
No one who's ever lived who rides
a bull until the bowls tired.
It doesn't happen.
You go flying.
So it's a matter of how long
does it take before you fail.
That's all it is.
It's like try to succeed
for as long as possible,
but you can't win.
And then does the work keeps
the bowl from crushing here?
That's a good question.
They have rodeo clowns.
They have a bunch of different
people that distractible.
But my beef was,
the guy was like,
well these here are training clowns are,
these are,
these are training bowls.
I go,
what do you,
does that mean?
He goes,
well,
they're not as aggressive
and like does that bold?
No,
he's a fucking training ball.
He doesn't know he's your training,
but what's a bull?
So you're basing it on how he's
thrown people off him in the past,
how he's going to throw these people off.
It's just,
just some sort of a random calculation
they making their cowboy mind.
And so we put these people on it and
they got launched and we launched,
it was really scary.
One girl,
it was really scary cause she only
weighed like 90 something pounds and she
just,
I mean it would the bold,
like for one second she was on this
boat and then she was literally flying
through the air and the bulls kicking
and the bull's foot just went right past
her face.
And I was like,
okay,
if that bolt kicked her face,
it would crush every bone in her face.
Even though she has a helmet on,
it would still probably
be crushed her helmet.
This is ridiculous.
And I think on that,
who approved that?
Shin,
NBC,
everybody that produced the show.
I think on that occasion they
essentially rolled the dice.
No one got hurt,
everyone was fine.
But I think it was a lot of luck.
And then the other times the
donkey comes a time where I said,
this is,
this is crazy,
you shouldn't do this.
I said,
the people don't want to eat.
Come.
Okay,
you can't just serve people come and
like you cook crossing some sort of hey
putting out propaganda.
That's funny you say that.
Like when you were talking about earlier
with the reality TV climbing stuff,
you won't follow me.
So as I actually saw like a pitch for
a climbing reality TV thing where they
were going through your downside.
Put that down.
What do you want me this photo,
he went to some AVN awards
because I brought you a present.
I'm like well thanks man.
He it,
it's just photo of guys with
giant Cox and their tight jeans.
Anyway,
so I saw this,
I was on the wall stop pitch for this
climbing show where they were like we're
going to,
it was supposed to be survivor meets a
meets ultimate fighter or something like
that but in climbing sense and so like
it was going to take non climbers and
then professional climbers and then we
teach them to solo and then we'd sold a
big walls and it was this whole production
and I was like how are you ever going
to have a show where you take non
climbers and you solo walls with them know
it's like you can't like,
you know,
you're like dude that's retarded.
It is retired.
And because also I actually,
I wrote back this scathing thing because
they asked me for a casting call type
deal.
I mean take your email forwarded to me
and I'll put it online and I did that.
We do that.
I can't vote for it.
Yeah.
Cause I was like people
would want to see it.
I was like what the heck?
You know I was like,
you might as well just have gladiators
like butcher and each other on TV.
Cause you're basically just
going to be watching carnage,
you know,
like,
I mean cause people will actually
die kind of messed up and you know,
I was like,
well that's it.
Nobody wants to see someone actually die.
You know it's so funny
you say that but yet this
is what you do every day.
You're like,
people will actually die.
But you do that
17 years right before it,
you know,
how much time would they need to be
conditioned before they could do anything?
What do you,
it depends on as he was.
I mean if it was something ultra easy,
I would just take any relatively fit
person and take them out with a lot of
supervision and you know,
if it's like a really easy solo.
Did you have a bunch of dudes at the
bottom holding a sheet by each corner?
Exactly.
Like you know like my ex girlfriend,
I mean I took her up a handful of really,
really easy,
this is kind of like extreme hiking,
you know,
but like,
I'd be scrolling right next to her.
She's taking her time and you're kind of
like talking her through it and you're
like,
oh,
you're good,
you're good.
You know.
So I mean like really fit like the person
at the top and give it some of that,
hey,
you know,
something like that.
That's how we're all freaked
out full of adrenaline.
I love,
but that's a wild ride.
Choose her or the mountain like did
you have to get in that situation?
Oh,
that kind of shit.
That's important.
That's actually,
let me see.
That was actually kind of those,
yeah,
that's about it.
Did that happen before it
was ever a girl was like,
I can't do this or what's,
she wasn't like me or the mountain,
but yeah.
I mean those are basically the issues.
Like you're way too much.
You're not like involved in or whatever.
Yeah.
So it was that way.
So it was chicks.
They want you,
they're greedy.
Yeah.
Once you give them some good deck,
they want you all the time.
I don't know if that was,
and it wasn't a problem.
It's probably not
your best though.
I was trying super hard.
Super hard.
Thanks for being honest.
Listen,
cat dude,
you're a fascinating guy.
I,
I think,
um,
I think what you're doing
is really a very unusual,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm always glad when I meet someone who's
doing something completely different,
you know,
different than me or,
it's one of the coolest things about
this podcast is that we can sit down with
people that,
I mean,
I probably would never
meet you in real life.
I mean,
maybe we exchange emails.
We have a little,
to be able to sit down face to face with
you and have a certain conversation for
whatever reason,
it only exists because of
a medium to display it.
You know,
it's,
it's really interesting.
I think it's,
um,
it's just important,
I think for a human being to realize that
there's a lot of different ways to be
a person.
So a lot of different people out there,
you know,
you probably would not be happy
if you were a singer in a band,
you know,
horrible.
Nobody else would be
happy either if be like,
oh no,
but you know what I'm saying?
That's their dream.
They're in front of the
mirror with a hairbrush.
You know,
it's funny you say that.
Like I actually,
I got invited to speak at
my old high school to a,
to tell the kids I was don't climb rocks.
And I was in gifted and talented type
program where everybody goes and becomes a
doctor or whatever.
And um,
they invited me there to speak to tell
the kids that they don't have to go to
college,
that if they want they can just go and
live their dream and do their thing and
whatever.
So it was actually a super satisfying
for me to go back to my old high school.
It'd be like
marijuana,
just like a high school in Sacramento.
Wow.
What a cool program mean.
Well,
it's the international baccalaureate.
It's kind of like AP program,
but kind of like high end,
like you know,
academic program.
So this is,
um,
not specific to that area.
This is a national program
where the program is national,
but the one that is in
that specific high school,
it's like quite good and they do
really well nationally and everything.
And so,
and it's,
you know,
it's just where I went to high school,
but so one of my old teachers ask me to
come back and tell the kids that like,
you know,
even though your parents are
expecting you to become a doctor,
like you don't have to like
you can just follow your dream,
travel the world,
do what you love to do,
that kind of thing.
It was like,
it was very satisfying to go
back and like have that talk,
you know,
after having gone through
the program and been like,
oh I need to go to university.
I got to get my degree know it'd be like,
you know what I mean?
I mean I think that's great and I think I,
and I really value education,
but like,
you know,
sometimes you just kind
of do what you love to do.
Yeah.
I value education as well,
but I completely agree with you and I
had the same issues coming out of high
school.
I went to college just so that
people didn't think I was a loser.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
It was really all I was competing
in taekwondo tournament's back then.
There was obviously no
money in that either.
But that's all I wanted to do.
And so I had to figure out
some way to not be a loser.
So I started going to
college while I was doing it.
Oh it was doing,
it's fucking up my training.
Just taking away time that I could
be napping instead of that I could be
napping.
When when you train that hard,
when you training for taekwondo tournament
especially that's like I didn't party
at all when I was in high school.
I didn't do and do it a couple of times.
Randomly gotten drunk at a party,
like over my entire high school career.
Maybe smoked pot like twice
or something like that.
But for the most part throughout high
school I was terrified that I was going to
get killed in a tournament and smashed.
So all I was doing it was just like
eating healthy and drinking water and you
know,
try to sleep as much as possible and
written and training like a demon.
So I went to that feeling of like
being out of high school and like,
this is no,
there's no future in this.
I was like,
what is this?
What am I doing?
Like this obsession,
it doesn't go anywhere.
It eventually worked out though.
That's an exactly.
But the feeling that I had,
that feeling of uncertainty was,
um,
it's,
I think it's so important to let other
people know that you had that same
feeling.
It's so important to do what you did
and get in front of his kids and go,
listen,
nobody has a map of where the
fuck you're supposed to go.
You could go anywhere.
And there's a lot of different
ways to make a living.
And if,
and if you see someone
who's doing something,
whether they're an author or a
painter or they're flying planes,
whatever it is,
if someone's doing it,
you can do it too.
It can be done
or you can do your own,
but he's doing it,
you know,
you have no one's doing it.
You can be like,
that
is what I want to do and God it,
I'm going to do it.
As long as it's logical,
unless someone needed to take you to
a doctor until you're fucking crazy,
you can't actually fly.
Right.
There's a little of that.
Yeah.
But you know,
all extreme examples of it's,
I think it's so important to do that.
It's so,
so important to give kids.
I mean,
how many times in your life have you seen
something that was inspiring that sort
of like pushed you and
they give you like this,
this feeling of confidence.
Like it was like,
Oh okay that guy did that.
God that this world is Kinda nutty.
There's a lot of different shit.
I think a guy like you is like
a really important example that,
yeah.
Maybe.
What did it feel like to do that speech?
Did you shit your pants?
I mean,
I'm talking to high school games.
I can't,
it's not a,
you can't be that nervous.
You know,
they're all like 16 and I'll try and
get laid except they're never going to,
cause they're all like little girl nerds.
Yeah.
That's what Brian comes in Florence.
So long as they're willing
to do this on film,
we can get them all ready.
It is not a problem.
I don't think that's really
the school to recruit for uh,
for porn.
No.
See you say that but say all want to get
laid so I don't see what you're saying.
As long as their penises and vaginas work,
I think we've got a problem there.
Yeah.
And we could solve it,
right Brian?
Yes.
That could be something that could derail
a of the career of an inspiring person
though he had too much high
end pussy at a young age.
It's like winning the lottery,
you know?
Cause if you won the lottery you like,
why would I work?
Why would I be inspired
to go do things right?
And I totally like,
I have this free money,
I'm going to play Xbox until I die.
Yeah.
It can kill motivation.
I think that also can happen if you
fuck above your head at a young age.
I never had that problem ruin you.
Still extremely motivated.
It can ruin you if you've
got a hold of some terror.
Patrick type chick.
When you were 18 years old,
you really think you could survive that.
That guy would wreck you.
That would be all you would think about.
You'd be on those climbing
peaks and instead of thinking
of your next foot hold,
you'd be thinking of her mouth on your
and your penis and then you could get
really problematic.
It wouldn't be focused,
he wouldn't keep your eyes on the prize.
The thrill of getting to the top but
somehow or another beat dwarfed by the
thrill of her mouth.
By the fee.
Yeah.
The memory of the thrill of
that knowledge that you know,
all you have to do is get in the same
room with her and shut the door and you'll
be having sex with her.
Is that all it takes?
No frigging.
Before she was your girlfriend?
I think she's actually married now.
I didn't use her and exists as an
example because she has loose morals.
Just exactly hot.
She's very nice.
Great.
Next person.
Yeah,
we've uh,
we've met before.
It's really nice,
but she's married.
She's got a baby and everything,
so I don't think you can fuck her up,
but I'm saying if you did
when you were 18 yeah,
it'd be a disaster for
your future productivity.
It could be,
right?
Yeah.
How do you jerk off when you're
in a tent and it's like you're,
you're in the middle of nowhere.
I like,
did you just save it until you get,
get back to civilization then you do the
same thing you do at home in a tent out
there hiking?
Yeah.
I mean why not?
I don't think a joke often tense.
As I say,
it's waterproof.
If you lived in a tent
or confident 10 yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
It gets to a certain
point where you're like,
all right,
I've got to just do this just
for maintenance for sure.
You've got to keep the pipes clean,
but it's all,
uh,
it's all on memory.
Do you bring like porn on a
phone or something like that?
Set it up.
Memory is kind of the way
I think or drawling it.
Kate fadings.
Have there ever been
pornographic cave paintings?
If her phone,
I sure there must be.
Well,
I mean porn.
Yeah.
It's interesting the idea that these
cave paintings represented reality cause
there's a lot of weird
shit that they drew.
Then like you know a lot of us ufologists
and big foot people look to as proof
of the fact these people experienced here.
Imagine if you looked at
all of human arteries.
Yeah.
Sketchy.
So like so like you know what,
there was a real Mickey mouse like
Mickey mouse and drill because there's a
drawing of Mickey Mouse.
Like that doesn't make any sense.
Like there was these guys
I watched finding big foot.
We've had the bigfoot hunter
Bobo on the show before.
Fascinating conversation.
It's the budget.
He's like honestly hunting big foot.
Yes.
I mean he's legit in the sense
that he's honestly honey big foot.
Oh yeah.
He believes he's had experiences.
Yeah.
Is he a Weirdo?
This is a little weird.
Yeah.
He could benefit from
Brian's program as well.
Prize
Brian's up,
whatever.
He's a,
but he's,
his life is dedicated to finding Sasquatch
apparently saw it once or twice or
something like that.
And it's been going on these expeditions
and they go looking for places where,
you know,
paypal,
what's
lot of fuckery involved.
But the,
the reason people keep going is because
there was an animal called gigantic
Pythagoras that lived as recently
as a hundred thousand years ago.
That was an eight foot,
10 foot tall by Peto primate
and enormous Animal Dakota.
The Co existed with humans,
you know,
just like we drew wooly mammoths.
This is a real animal.
So when they have these cave
paintings and drawings of this big,
tall,
hairy thing,
it may very well have been something that
existed and died off because it lived
in Asia and must much like people came
to North America following the Bering
strait.
Yeah.
It,
uh,
it also could have done
the exact same thing.
They think it's really possible,
especially because of the density of
the forest in the Pacific northwest.
In fact,
Jane Goodall,
the primatologist,
she,
she's pretty certain that there's,
um,
a,
an actual undiscovered primate
living in the Pacific northwest.
She said she believes 100%.
She said,
John,
I'm absolutely certain,
or something like that.
I forget her exact quote,
but I thought coming from
a primatologist like her,
that's something to be considered.
But it also could be romantic confirmation
bias and now she could just be
psyched about monkeys and hoping
there's a big one out there.
And that's how,
what finger blast herself
to sleep every night.
Thinking about this big AP in Rio.
Catch him,
please.
Proved me.
Right.
Oh,
that's how she,
maybe not,
I don't think I've ever heard anybody
talking about Jane Goodall in a sexual
sense.
That's how I got in
trouble in science class.
Um,
there was a,
uh,
a,
a woman,
uh,
who was,
this science teacher that was a,
this a kid who was a high school
quarterback who was like really smart kid.
He's very,
very charming and charismatic and he
would flirt with all the teachers to kind
of try to get better grades.
So,
uh,
I got to class early and,
I had,
uh,
I drew a picture of him,
Bang her,
and she was screaming out,
do it,
do it to me.
Monkey style,
like my hero,
Jane Goodall.
And I like when I got in trouble
or that I could see that.
Yeah,
I got try.
That's what,
before I became a comedian,
most of my comedy ideas were expressed
from cartoons because I was sort of a
drawer.
I drew an illustrator when I was young
and I used to do a lot of comic book type
stuff and so I would draw like teachers
doing something fucked up and get in
trouble.
You could do this one teacher,
she just,
where a lot of makeups I
drove without her makeup,
but she was a werewolf.
It's fucking stupid.
But they got,
they suspended me for that.
You know,
some shit that you would get on the
Internet every day and you would laugh at
it.
You would l o l l U l.
Z back in the day.
Yeah.
Back in the day.
Kinda in trouble faster.
It's,
did you get in trouble
at all in high school?
You know,
you're a good kid.
I never got less than,
than,
they never got less than an a in anything.
Nope.
Wow.
I graduate if I get 4.7 or something.
That's amazing.
So and you went from there to college and
just like this is just not stimulating
enough and not,
yeah,
just wasn't interested,
you know.
Wow.
It's like I would rather be homeless.
Yeah.
Do you anticipate keeping
this lifestyle until you die?
Traveling,
living in a van,
climbing whenever you can?
Yeah.
Well maybe,
maybe not the full time travel until I
die just because at some point I'm sure I
wanted to like settle down.
Do you think you'll ever move
up to a mobile home right now?
I'll probably get a real
house at some point.
At some point in time.
Yeah.
The thing is it's hard to find a
place that I'd want to live full time.
You ever been in boulder?
Yeah,
I have.
The folder is actually,
yeah.
That's like the heart of climbing in the
u s a bunch of climbing companies are
based there.
Is it really?
And there's so much climbing
on the front range there.
They're like,
yeah.
That's like,
that's the heart of us climbing.
Yeah,
I was there.
Someone that died,
someone fell off one of
those flat fitness and elder.
He's out of Canyon probably.
Yeah,
it was it people,
I mean a handful of people
die there every year.
Probably every,
yeah,
it seems like it.
And do you guys look at those people?
Just people that are just inexperienced,
shouldn't have January
there's a different,
I mean there's a,
there's a publication every year,
accidents in North American mountaineering
and it's just a list of every
accident that happened over the year.
And they have analysis
and causes and you know,
I mean some accidents
you read and you're like,
what an idiot,
you know,
and then some accidents.
What have you ever read?
Uh,
okay.
Like the first thing that comes to mind,
but I've always found just totally
comedic is a odd half dome.
There's like this long
horizontal traverse where like,
you basically walk across
this little tiny ledge.
It's like the photos.
I don't know if you've
seen any on the internet.
There's a classic photo of me standing
on this little tiny ledge and it looks
all crazy.
But,
so,
um,
if you don't place protection across
the length of the ledge and you fall,
you're going to just swing like,
you know,
I mean it's just like a pendulum straight
across and there's a corner at the
other end of it.
So if you swing the distance,
you're just going to swing into this
corner and just get totally messed up.
And so,
um,
I read an accident,
it was like a Korean woman climbing,
you know,
going big walling or whatever.
It's like their first wall and she gets
up there and she like takes out the
piece of production is like,
well,
I'm going to take the swing rather
than like crawling across the ledger,
whatever.
She's just like,
takes the swing augers into the corner,
breaks both their ankles and um,
you know,
and you're like,
what an idiot.
You know,
because it's basically like,
imagine holding onto a rope swing and
looking at a brick wall and being like,
I'm going to swing into that wall,
you know,
with a 90 degree angle.
Like,
I mean,
you know,
so you read an accident
like that and you're like,
what was she thinking?
Because it's like simple,
you know,
any kid would be like,
this looks like it's
going to be a terrible,
I mean it's pretty simple physics,
you know.
But then
at the other end of the spectrum you
see accidents where it's just like some
totally safe family man
or something and like,
you know,
an ice pillar collapses on him,
like say when you're
climbing or something,
because that happens a lot
when people are ice climbing,
things just collapse or whatever and you
just get hit with ice and you're done.
Yeah.
Or like rock fall or
something or like fricking,
I'm the head of Nols,
I think,
you know the national
outdoor leadership school,
like the outdoor program,
he was climbing some peak in Montana or
Wyoming or somewhere and tourist stuff
on top.
We're throwing rocks off the top.
Like,
oh,
we're on top.
And he got hit by a rock and died.
Oh,
you hear that kind of an accident.
And you were like,
that just sucks.
Because I mean,
you feel bad for the
dude on top of it too,
because you're like,
how could they know?
And the rock had poop on it.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's a big old rock.
It's really,
you're hurling rocks.
You ever thought about that?
Good point,
Brian.
Yeah,
no,
no.
For sure.
And you say,
Hey,
they're down below,
throw my shit.
And it's attached to a rock.
Yeah.
Nope.
Everyone cool with this
[inaudible] report form to throw rocks.
I mean,
shit putting is actually
strongly discouraged,
but like generally that only happens
like early morning when you started like
during the night and then you
have to do and then whatever.
And you assume those are gonna be there.
Have you ever had any
weird wildlife experiences?
Mountain lions,
bears,
anything like that?
I mean,
I've had,
I've had bears eat my
backpack or a couple of times,
so wheelie.
Okay.
Yeah,
I've heard photos on my phone
of a bear eating my pag though.
But that happens when you send me all
the time is the pair of the bears are so
desensitized to humans that they're like,
you used to interacting,
but there's been a few desks in Yosemite,
not for embarrassed.
Yes.
There has been two very,
very recently.
How recently?
Really recently,
people getting killed by a bear.
Yeah.
You sure?
I'm apple died from the
Honda virus this last season.
Absolutely.
100% positive.
Yosemite in the winter.
Grizzly bear.
Hold on there.
No Grizzlies in California.
It's a their blackberries.
Yosemite is not just California though,
right?
Oh,
you're talking about Yellowstone.
did I say yes?
You'll 70.
Okay.
Yeah.
In Yellowstone there are grizzlies and
they probably did get killed by bears
grizzly.
Yeah.
There's California.
They killed the lion.
All stone grizzly kills hikers.
Yeah.
To Yellowstone,
Yellowstone,
Yellowstone recently.
I confused the two together.
No,
that makes sense.
Um,
yeah,
but yellow in,
so they killed off all the bears.
They had grizzlies and
killed them in the state
flag of California,
whatever.
It's a grizzly bear.
But,
uh,
they killed the last crusade
and like 1850 or something.
Yeah.
The last California,
it says it here that there were,
there were killed.
That's,
that's fascinating.
Because,
um,
do any of them,
because they know that um,
polar bears travel like long distances.
Do grizzly bears ever tried to
come from places that they don't?
I don't think so.
I mean,
I mean like how far
is that what it would be if that is
kind of a grand place to work or us,
it's a lot of desert apparently there
because they know that mountain minds have
made that trip,
which is really kind of
creepy because mountain lion,
it's really interesting.
Mountain line pressure
has changed because a,
they don't,
they don't hunt them.
1922,
it was the last time a
graphs killed in California,
the Sierra foothills in 1922,
the last woman,
the mountain lions,
uh,
are hunted in Nevada,
but in California they
don't have them anymore.
So they've started moving in Nevada
or from Nevada into California.
It's really interesting.
It's like they've sort of figured out
that there's a hunting pressure in
college.
She,
I was just reading this article about,
uh,
about urban animals,
about like small predators,
like foxes and coyotes and stuff,
adapting to urban environments and how,
you know,
there's footage of like a coyote going
to an intersection looking both ways and
then crossing the road instead of these,
basically animals learn the
same way anybody else does.
It's pretty funny stuff to think about.
Like a little Fox,
you know,
like living in a skyscraper and
like using the streets just goes,
yeah,
it is interesting.
They've uh,
they've got a bunch of coyotes that they
have tagged that are living in Chicago.
And uh,
that was actually the example.
The article I was reading
was about Chicago,
isn't it?
Not?
I mean,
I think there's like
60 of them and they do,
they eat the rats and all that
shit and it's really weird.
Like they barely have track of him.
He's the king of like,
I think they have radio
bands on them and stuff.
Yeah.
All the,
all the berries in a Yosemite
or tagged or they were all like,
so when you,
well,
I mean,
except for a little cups and stuff.
But yeah,
they tagged the bears each season.
So Yosemite is California.
Yellow stone is part of California.
No,
no concern is Wyoming.
And I dunno if it's a surrounding states,
but it's Wyoming and that has bears.
They have grizzlies.
Yeah.
Do you ever go up there hiking?
I have as a tourist
and as a kid and stuff.
And the Tetons that Grand Teton
national park is also like a joining
Yellowstone.
So the Yosemite bears
at attacked your bag.
We're just bears.
Yeah,
they're just,
they're just little bike.
They just eat your food and stuff.
They don't really talk to people.
No,
I don't think anyone's ever
been attacked by a bear.
And he 70 really?
I mean,
they're really like,
they're cute little bears.
And I mean,
they're totally,
I mean,
they're cuddly looking,
but it's just,
they're around people so much that they
get used to it and then they eat your
shit.
It's kind of annoying.
Yeah.
When you see people,
uh,
feeding bears out of their car,
you want to punch him in the face.
Yeah.
That's,
that's a real
problem.
You don't see that committee,
but you have to,
uh,
is that Yellowstone where they do that?
Maybe.
Did you have to see that video of a,
there's a,
it's one of those faces of death videos
where a guy got out of the car to take
photos with a grizzling and,
uh,
truck did.
They were feeding the bears.
Do you?
I can choose a tourist or
something to fucking come.
I don't know what hearted.
I don't know what his deal was,
but there's a video of the guy,
he's a,
he hit a car.
Oh yeah.
Eh,
you got fucking mall in front of
everybody when they were filming it,
they wanted to take pictures of him out
there feeding the bearings fucked up
here.
Saw him now like bitch,
he has like,
why take the little piece of meat
when I can take the whole piece of it?
Yeah.
That's pretty messed up.
People don't understand how
dangerous grizzlies are.
They,
they think that just because they could
be in the car and throw the stuff out
the window,
that somehow or another you
could stand outside the car.
Like a guy was really ballsy.
Thinks he could go out there and do that.
But that's a lot of meat
cause dangle in front of them.
Like you look like meat,
man.
They know like me for sure.
Have you seen the video?
Did we show that video?
Brian of the guy,
uh,
in Antarctica who's in
the grizzly box or the,
uh,
not,
are not Antarctica.
Um,
uh,
not,
he's uh,
he's in the Arctic and he's in a
polar bear plexiglass like box.
Did we show that
it works by bears?
No,
no,
no.
He,
he went up there on purpose.
We'll pull it up for you.
Just so you take a look at it.
Like an armored case.
Yeah.
He,
they,
it's an upcoming documentary
that they filmed,
um,
that they,
they designed this piece of equipment,
this,
the structure just specifically,
so this guy could be dropped off there
and have these bears try to get at him
while he's like sitting there were these
enormous polar bear is like chewing at
it and sniffing it and opening
his mouth and tried to bite it.
It's so terrifying when you're watching
it because it seems like kind of a
tense,
oh,
it's so intense.
Well,
he can't,
they can't get in.
They designed it.
Well,
can I get it?
But there's like spots where you know
like air slots when it gets to the air
it's like,
and then it opens its mouth
and he's trying to bite it.
Yeah,
it can't quite,
but it's so big.
I didn't understand for whatever
reason I knew they were big,
but it takes seeing it next to a
person to really conceptualize like,
oh,
oh God.
I mean it's like 12 feet tall.
It's unbelievably big.
And this guy's in there and this thing
has just got its arms around the box and
it's trying to bite it and it's trying
to figure out where the fuck it is.
Here it is.
Look at that box at this guy he's in and
he's up there just chilling around for
this.
Uh,
what is the BBC?
I'll,
I'll give it a plug so that
people know what's Debbie's.
Yeah,
it's a BBC documentary.
A polar bear
from Gordon boot.
Cannon Gordon Be Kannon.
Do they,
what is the name of the show?
It's a nature documentary.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Hey.
There
is thousands of times
more powerful than mine.
It's gathering information before they
approaches like it would when stoking a
seal.
My sand is strongest at the weakest point,
the door
fragile,
that door open systematically
trying from all angles.
Look at the size of
that appreciation for what this animal is.
One of the most powerful
animals on the planet.
Almost intimidating animals on the planet.
One of the few animals that
actually see us as food.
Wonder how that guy got signed
to a gap.
You can sniff my nose
if you haven't seen this video,
folks.
You've got to go online and just watch it.
This is just a clip.
The video,
uh,
is,
I believe in.
There's a,
okay there.
It already,
it's called the polar bear family
and me and it aired a Monday,
January 7th on BBC two.
But you can,
you can find it online and you got to
see it just to see how fucking I same
breastfed.
I'm totally vain.
Gross.
It was amazing.
Well,
I would imagine that a guy like
you that's so into thrills,
like that would be a,
well,
I'm not going to get eaten by bears.
Mean.
I'm not saying that you
would want to do it,
but I though it'd be fascinating to you.
Yeah,
that's pretty hardcore.
Yeah.
If you ever had a trunk climb,
anything ice,
anything like Sharon when I
was coming for the first time,
like last week in Salt Lake.
Oh really?
Which a climb,
like a waterfall is or
something like that.
Is that what it's called?
Ice Climbing?
Yeah.
Basically it's like a watercourse
and like ice builds up and yeah,
so like what we did was called
the great white ice cold,
but it's kind of like a,
it's almost like a steep sort of wall
slash gully that like forms up with a lot
of steps ice.
So you like climb a little cliff advice
and then you go up like a steep snow
slope and then another ice cliff,
whatever.
Is that real unpredictable?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it can be.
I would think that there's a lot of,
sure.
It's much less predictable than rock,
you know,
because it's constantly like changing
temperature and you just fall off for
sure.
For sure.
That's part of the reason
I've never been that into it.
I think it's kind of sketch.
So you just sketchy.
So you just did it a
as a just like fuck it,
let me just do this.
Well just to learn how it basically,
um,
cause I'm pretty sure I might be doing
some trips to like Alaska or something
this year and um,
the could climb bigger granite rock faces.
But the thing is when you
go to places like that,
I mean it's common like
a big granite wall,
which is what I normally do.
But then on top there'll be like some
sections of ice or whatever and you have
to at least be comfortable like hiking
in your crampons and things like that.
So I was like,
well,
I've got to at least learn
how to use all this gear,
you know.
So I went out and practiced.
Do you have any desire to do Everest?
I Dunno.
I mean if somebody would pay for the trip,
I probably would just feel
like the life experience.
But it's definitely not
like a climbing thing.
Actually somebody posted some rant that
you had maybe from standup comedy or
something about making fun
of people on mountains,
which I was like,
you know,
Everest one.
Yeah,
totally.
But it was material.
I mean,
well the thing is climate isn't in front
of that stuff too because like what
people do on Everest is so far removed
from actual climbing that it's like,
you know,
they don't anymore really?
Well,
yeah.
It's like,
yeah,
it's a hike,
but I don't know if it was
your ranch or another one.
But I mean,
you're basically hiring Sherpas to
do all the actual climbing for you.
And then you know,
if you're like a
conventional western client,
whatever,
you know,
I mean,
you're basically being
shuttled up a mountain.
I was like,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Who actually had it.
So I climbed Kilimanjaro like that
with my girlfriend and what my then
girlfriend and September and I'm just
as kind of like a tourist vacation,
you know,
like Oh,
it'll be fun.
And it was my first experience with people
like carrying all your stuff for you
in setting up for 10 for
you and doing all the work.
And I was like,
dude,
this is a pretty,
it's pretty friggin buddy.
I mean,
I felt weird about it,
but like,
I mean it is a vacation.
I can see why people would do that for,
you know,
to feel extreme.
Cause you're like,
oh I climbed the biggest
mountain in Africa,
but it was like a dude brewing
the tea every day in that format,
you know?
But,
but as far as like going
somewhere with a girlfriend,
you know,
I was like,
oh,
it's a pretty legit vacation is cool
and we get to see more of Africa.
You know?
That's like full service camping.
Yeah,
no it was,
it was like,
I was like,
dude,
this is as good as I
live at home or better,
you know,
like this.
It's pretty legit,
you know?
That's fascinating man.
Listen man,
dude,
you,
you live an amazing life.
It's really awesome.
And I really appreciate you taking the
time to come in here and sit down and
shoot the shit with us.
It was fascinating and intriguing and,
uh,
and,
and thank you and best of luck
to you and the stay healthy.
And I would love to have you
come back here and do the scan,
man.
I'm sure people,
thanks for the love you.
We'd love to hear your stories.
And if you want to do
that thing with Brian,
he's down this weekend.
Are you gonna come to the UFC?
Is that all?
Maybe I'll ask you about it on.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
this is a rare opportunity.
This doesn't happen that often where
you're going to be in the same thing.
I might actually,
we're going to have to do it.
We'll talk.
Thank you very much.
Really appreciate it.
You guys.
Alex Honnold ladies,
gentlemen,
please follow him on Twitter.
It's Alex Honnold,
I'm sorry.
Don't go to the ald cause
that's a different dude.
Yeah,
that guy's getting bombed on right now.
Yeah.
H spell it for forever.
[inaudible] Oh,
the H.
O.
N.
L.
D.
Thank you very much.
Followup Brian Red Ban Red,
B a n and you probably already follow me
or you probably already file Bron too,
so whatever.
Why am I talking a thank you to tim.com
go to rogan.ting.com and save 25 bucks
off of a free phone are free phone
or an android phone or service.
A contract free is what I meant to say.
Awesome android goodness,
and a a very ethical company.
Thank you.
Also to what kerosene games
for their blade runner game.
Go check it out.
Download it off iTunes.
It's $2 99 cents and it's
totally fucking worth it.
Thank you to [inaudible] dot com go to
o n n I t and use the code Dean Brogan.
You will save 10% off
any supplements tomorrow.
We have Tim Ferris,
so we will see you guys all tomorrow.
Tim Ferriss has some really crazy,
cool shit to tell us and he's a
fascinating and really unique individuals,
so if you've never heard of him,
he's the author of the
four hour work week.
The four hour body and just a
brilliant dude and a great guy.
So we'll see him tomorrow.
We'll see you tomorrow,
and that's it.
Can I see a big kiss?
[inaudible].